Buenos días a todas las personas que ya
se están conectando. Por acá veo que
tenemos teníamos casi 100 personas que
nos estaban esperando. Qué emoción
comenzar con este super hackaton. Esta
mañana les vamos a dar la bienvenida.
Tenemos una ceremonia de apertura muy
especial donde vamos a conocer un poco
sobre col subsidio, sobre 30x, que
muchos de ustedes ya deben conocer un
poco de ambas empresas, pero les
explicamos por qué nos unimos en este
evento para estar juntos y justamente
poder celebrar la innovación abierta en
conjunto y contar con todos ustedes para
lograr solucionar retos que hoy tiene
Col Subsidio desde las ideas, desde la
tecnología. Así que bienvenidos por
estar acá. Me alegra muchísimo ver que
ya somos más de 800 personas que estamos
dentro de este de este hackatom. Me
encanta. Y bueno, por acá ya comienzo a
ver David, Uriel, nos acaban de decir,
"Buenos días, excelente. Cuéntenos un
poco de de dónde nos de dónde están
conectados y mientras vamos a hacer unos
un par de minutitos para que a las 9:5
comencemos con toda la agenda. Entonces,
cuéntenos desde dónde están conectados.
Bogotá, desde Medellín, desde otros
países, Venezuela.
Nicaragua, no sé, tenemos personas de
México, tenemos incluso personas de
Estados Unidos y otras partes de del
mundo. Así que por allí vayan
contándonos de dónde están. Bien, desde
el norte de Santander, me encanta. Desde
Bogotá, maravilloso.
Quito Chocó, me encanta. Quiero ir para
allá. Cali, amo Cali. Cali es de mis
lugares favoritos de Colombia. A ver,
muy bien. Cundinamarca también.
Muchas personas de Bogotá. Bueno, les
cuento que desde el viernes vamos a
tener un espacio presencial en Bogotá,
en las oficinas de, bueno, en el club La
Colina de Col Subsidio, un lugar
hermosísimo. Vamos a estar en en el
espacio de Concepta y las personas que
ya fueron seleccionadas para participar
presencial ya tienen su correo. Igual
vamos hoy a mandarle a todas las
personas que fueron seleccionadas, le
vamos a mandar un recordatorio aquellas
que todavía no nos han confirmado su
cupo para que pues recuerden confirmarlo
y asistir. Ya somos más de 150.
Inicialmente eran 100 cupos, pero ahí
convencimos a Cor subsidio de que nos
dejara llevar 50 personas más y nos
dejó. Eh, veo aquí personas de
Cartagena. Amo Cartagena, me encanta.
Juan David. A ver. Y nada, tenemos una
persona que está desde el Centro de
Comercio Internacional representando a
Bucaramanga. Excelente, Bucaramanga,
Medellín, Casanare. Espectacular, me
encanta. Bien, ya somos 123 personas
conectadas. Recuerden que todas estas
charlas van a quedar grabadas,
completamente disponibles, directamente
en nuestro YouTube. ¿Cuál es ese
YouTube? Es 30x Aids. Ahí van a
encontrar todas las grabaciones, todos
los enlaces de en vivo y de hecho, en
cuanto ustedes quieran conocer, bueno,
la el cronograma, ya lo van a tener
disponible también en nuestra página
principal de innovación.corsubsidio.com
y allí van a tener el cronograma, van a
poder darle clic directamente para ver
las charlas. Si la charla ya pasó, van a
entrar a estos videos grabados y si la
charla está en vivo, van a poder verla
inmediatamente ya disponible. Si la
charla está por venir, van a poder darle
clic en notificar. Bien. Me encanta ya
ver Ah, mira, tenemos alguien desde
Perú. Me encanta. Maravilloso que haya
muchas personas uniéndose. Una persona
dijo que es de Mérida, Mérida,
Venezuela, Mérida, México. Cuéntanos
allí.
Excelente. Tenemos a una startup de eh
desarrollo de software presente desde
Medellín, desde el multiverso. Me
encanta Valencia, Venezuela. Maravilloso
verlos a todos acá. Excelente. Bueno,
vamos a comenzar a compartirles esta
presentación de hoy para que vayamos
avanzando con nuestra super ceremonia de
apertura que tenemos eh preparados para
ustedes. Hoy nos va a acompañar el
equipo de Col Subsidio directamente para
que podamos hacerle preguntas de call
subsidio. Y yo sé que muchos de ustedes
van a tener muchísimas preguntas de los
retos. Les voy a contar cómo va a
funcionar. Vamos a presentar los retos
de forma general esta mañana y más tarde
vamos a tener durante la tarde de hoy
vamos a tener un espacio donde ustedes
van a poder hablar directamente con h,
digamos los dueños de esos retos
internamente con subsidio, que son los
gerentes, son las personas que trabajan
directamente con esos retos. Entonces,
ya eh durante la tarde ustedes van a
poder hacerle todas las consultas que
tengan bien específicas sobre el reto
que ustedes quieren participar
directamente a estos a a estas personas.
Entonces, ya voy a comenzar a compartir
aquí mi pantalla.
Tururu. Vamos por acá.
Perfecto. Bien, entonces bienvenidos por
acá a este a esta super ceremonia de
apertura. Les voy a comentar un poco
cómo va a ser esta sesión. Primero,
bueno, acabamos de tener esa bienvenida
apertura con ustedes. Estamos en este
momento de esos 10 minuticos de
bienvenidos, de hacer este rapping, esta
este momento de de simplemente
conocernos un poquito, saber desde dónde
se están conectando. Ya vemos que están
157 personas, entonces hemos estado
dejando espacio para que se unan más
personas en vivo. Luego vamos a tener
una presentación con Col Subsidio de Col
Subsidio directamente con Juan Manuel
Botía que es el gerente de innovación
que es prácticamente quien está
liderando la innovación dentro de Col
subsidio. Igual él nos va a comentar
mucho más de qué es con subsidio, por
qué están interesados en que nosotros
les apoyamos, les apoyemos a resolver
estos retos. También ahí me voy a colar
un momento y voy a contarles un poquito
sobre 30x y después vamos a tener a
Andrea Garzón que nos va a contar un
poco sobre bueno, cuáles son esos retos
y tracks que tenemos. Recuerden que
tenemos retos, aquí dice salud, bueno,
no debería decir salud, es de hotelería,
vivienda y crédito. Y eh también después
de eso les voy a comentar un poco sobre
las reglas, criterios, evaluación de
entregables. Vamos a hablar un poco de
la logística de la semana, cuál es el
cronograma, por dónde vamos a hablar.
Eh, sí, en efecto, eh, Ana es hotelería
salud. Es que justamente cambiamos el
reto hace poco y por eso por eso algunas
cositas dicen el reto de salud, pero ya
saben que es eh hotelería allí. Igual
todo pasa en vivo y aquí ven que estamos
en vivo por este tipo de cosas. Luego eh
en la logística desde la semana también
les contaremos un poquito sobre
mentores, premios y vamos a pasar a
tener un espacio de preguntas y
respuestas, un espacio totalmente
abierto donde ustedes nos podrán hacer
todas las preguntas que tengan. Aquí ya
estamos haciendo el cambio. Gracias,
André. Y eh después de eso pasamos
directamente a el cierre y formación de
equipos. Lo que vamos a hacer es
invitarlos a que vayan a un Zoom donde
todas las personas que quieran o estén
buscando equipo van a poder hacer
preguntas directa eh directamente allí y
van a poder decir, "Hola, por ejemplo,
un un ejemplo que me encantaría darles
es si ustedes están buscando equipo
pueden entrar en el WhatsApp, hay un
grupo que se llama Busco equipo y una
recomendación que les doy es que digan,
"Hola, mi nombre es Sandra Carrillo,
esta es mi experiencia y estoy buscando
un equipo para un el reto de hotelería,
por ejemplo, o el reto de vivienda y así
de una otras personas van a decir, "Me
encanta este perfil, voy a conectarlo."
Eso es lo que vamos a hacer durante la
sesión de formación de equipos. Así que
los esperamos por allí. Y bueno, para
comenzar y ahora sí le voy a dar el paso
a Juan Manuel. Me encanta tenerte por
acá. Muchas gracias por hacer esto
posible, Juan Manuel. Eres nuestro
principal aliado en este sentido.
Hola, Sandra. No, yo creo que los
aliados para nosotros son ustedes,
porque indudablemente para nosotros como
organización contemplar todos estos
escenarios y estas metodologías de
innovación abierta son un reto muy
importante. Y ante todo, créanme eh
todos los que estén conectados que
nosotros somos unos convencidos de que
trabajar con actores externos, trabajar
con startups, trabajar con estudiantes,
trabajar con desarrolladores, trabajar
con todas las personas que van a estar
conectadas con nosotros esta semana, eso
nos potencia a todos. los va a potenciar
ustedes, pero también a nosotros nos va
a permitir encontrar una serie de
soluciones para contribuir a que este
país siga cerrando brechas sociales y
que sigamos de verdad siendo esa caja de
compensación líder, la caja de
compensación que tiene un portafolio de
servicios más completo a nivel eh de
todas las cajas, pero también ante todo
seguir siendo una empresa innovadora que
piensa innovar no solamente por
nosotros, por mejorar eficiencia, por
seguir siendo primeros, sino por tener
las mejores soluciones. sociales en
Colombia y, por qué no decirlo en
América Latina. Entonces, ese es nuestro
reto. Entonces, gracias Sandra eh por
haber creído en este proyecto, por
acompañarnos y porque hoy vamos a
materializar este ejercicio de nuestra
primer jacatón.
Me encanta, Juan Manuel. Bueno, te cedo
el espacio para que tú nos comentes un
poquito de qué es con subsidio. Acá te
acompaño con las eh las diapositivas.
Voy a estar pendiente cada vez que
finalices una idea pasar a la siguiente,
pero cualquier cosa me dices, pasamos
ahí. Vamos y nos vamos organizando,
Sandra. De eso se trata, aprovechemos
las ventajas de la tecnología, porque
efectivamente eh tenemos algo más de 800
personas que se han inscrito a nuestra
jacatón. Hay personas de más de 10
países, eh hay personas eh lógicamente
muchos son de Colombia, hay otros de
México, hay de Uruguay, hay de Chile,
hay de Estados Unidos, eh hay de Perú.
Eh, entonces vean que tenemos una gama
de personas que todos ustedes sean
bienvenidos y quisimos como punto de
partida contarles qué es col subsidio.
Entonces, nosotros como col subsidio
somos una corporación de derecho
privado. Muchas personas no tienen esto
muy claro y esta es una empresa privada
que pertenece a todas las empresas que
se afilian a con subsidio y que son a
quienes nosotros tenemos que escucharles
las directrices que nos dan para
precisamente estructurar los programas y
los servicios sociales que ofrecemos
para todos los trabajadores de esas
empresas afiliadas. Más adelante les voy
a comentar algunas cifras, pero les voy
anticipando, nosotros tenemos ya cerca
de 1,illón y medio de afiliados y cerca
de 100,000 empresas en Colombia que
están escogid subsidio como la mejor eh
caja de compensación y su mejor aliado
para hacer realidad ese propósito de
desarrollar socialmente programas para
el beneficio del trabajador colombiano y
sus familias. ¿Cómo nos financiamos
nosotros? con unos aportes
empresariales. Cada mes cuando las
empresas pagan sus nóminas eh tienen la
obligación legal de aportar a una caja
de compensación el 4% de esas nóminas y
nosotros con esos recursos lo que
hacemos es precisamente esa inversión
social en una gama de servicios y
programas que más adelante les voy a
comentar. Y de alguna manera, ¿cuál es
la esencia de esos servicios? que están
enmarcados en unas normas que existen en
Colombia sobre lo que es el subsidio
familiar, la protección de las familias,
la seguridad y la responsabilidad
social, que son unas dinámicas que se
han venido extendiendo por todo el
mundo. ¿Listo? Sigamos, Andre. Y en todo
este contexto de de qué es el subsidio,
quiero compartir con ustedes cuál es
este enfoque de trabajo y es que cada
gobierno nacional en Colombia trae una
política económica y de desarrollo
social. Y nosotros articulamos muchísimo
esas políticas de gobierno nacional que
justamente en unos 15 días en Colombia
vamos a tener cambio de gobierno y llega
un nuevo gobierno con unas nuevas
políticas y unas nuevas directrices y
cada año lo que hacemos es entender esas
directrices, esa política social y de
alguna manera empezar a integrar a esas
empresas afiliadas que buscan también el
bienestar de sus trabajadores. Y si
unimos lo que buscan las empresas, lo
que busca el gobierno y lo que nosotros
como caja de compensación tenemos, lo
que hacemos es generar un portafolio que
mejore la calidad de vida de esos
trabajadores en Colombia. Y a partir de
ese mejoramiento de calidad de vida,
¿qué hacemos? que un trabajador que ya
está un poco despreocupado por cubrir
sus necesidades básicas gracias a los
servicios y programas que nosotros
ofrecemos, es un trabajador que
indudablemente es más productivo, es una
persona que está concentrada al 100% en
su labor, en su empresa, y a partir de
ello, un trabajador más productivo hace
que las organizaciones, indudablemente
sean unas empresas más competitivas y
ese es el aporte para que este país siga
desarrollándose, creciendo y que nos
convirtamos de verdad en un país
próspero y en paz y ese es el aporte de
alguna manera de que cuando se genera
empleo hay desarrollo social y ese es el
gran propósito que todos perseguimos
acá. Sigamos.
Entonces, en todo este contexto ustedes
se preguntarán, bueno, ¿y con subsidio,
¿por qué es la caja de compensación más
representativa a nivel nacional? Y tengo
que compartir una serie de datos con
ustedes. Por un lado, porque nuestras
operaciones ya abarcan y tenemos
presencia en cerca de 16 departamentos.
En algunos de ellos tenemos hoteles, en
otros tenemos droguerías, en otros
tenemos centros médicos y esa y y ahí
hemos venido, digamos, como
extendiéndonos y haciendo presencia
donde todo lo que son las normas
legales, donde nuestro marco de
actuación y ante todo nuestro propósito
social nos permite hacer presencia para
mejorar calidad de vida de las personas.
Yo creo que aquí seguramente hay gente
de muchísimas partes de Colombia y en
muchas de ellas les aseguro que puede
haber una droguería con subsidio o un
centro médico con subsidio o un hotel
principalmente en en Meta, en Boyacá,
etcétera. H a nivel de Cundinamarca,
Cundinamarca tiene algo más de 113 114
eh municipios. Nosotros hacemos
presencia directa en 60 de ellos, o sea,
en la mitad de los municipios de
Cundinamarca nosotros tenemos una
prestación directa de servicios y cuando
ya nos concentramos particularmente en
Bogotá, tenemos 254
puntos de atención entre lo que pueden
ser colegios, eh droguerías, eh centros
médicos, centros de recreación,
etcétera. Esa es la cantidad de puntos
que tenemos eh presentes y de presencia
física en Bogotá en este momento.
Entonces, como ustedes pueden ver, esta
es una corporación que no solamente
tiene una filosofía muy clara, sino que
efectivamente hemos podido materializar
una serie de puntos de atención que
buscan es precisamente facilitarle a
nuestros afiliados y a sus familias
acceder a esa variedad de portafolio que
nosotros tenemos. Sigamos, Sandra.
Y en ese contexto ustedes se
preguntarán, ¿por qué nos cuentan todo
esto? Y yo quiero iniciar acá por este
círculo que ustedes observen en la parte
derecha de la pantalla. Es primero,
¿cuál es nuestro propósito? Se los había
mencionado anteriormente, es generar
oportunidades para cerrar brechas
sociales. En nuestros países,
desafortunadamente, las oportunidades no
han estado para todas las personas. Hm.
el estudio, eh a veces acceder a él es
complicado, el tener vivienda es
difícil, el tener buena atención en
salud a veces es también eh una cuestión
que se va enredando por muchos
procedimientos que existen, etcétera.
Acceder a un hotel, acceder a un centro
recreativo, muchos años se pensó que era
solamente un beneficio para las personas
de mayores ingresos. Yo tengo que
compartir con ustedes que desde el año
1957 se creó col subsidio precisamente
con esa inspiración que es darle a los
trabajadores afiliados la oportunidad de
acceder a servicios con calidad,
servicios que mejoren la calidad de vida
de sus familias. Col subsidio fue de las
primeras instituciones a nivel nacional
en ofrecer educación femenina, fue los
primeros en ofrecer programas de
hotelería. También fuimos los primeros
en ofrecer eh programas de crédito y
fomento de industrias familiares,
problemas eh programas culturales,
etcétera. Entonces, nosotros decimos
internamente que esta organización
siempre ha sido una empresa muy
innovadora. Muchos de los programas y
servicios que se ofrecen a nivel
nacional, eh, afortunadamente han sido,
digamos, abanderados desde con subsidio.
compartimos con otras cajas de
compensación a nivel nacional lo que
hacemos, lo que estructuramos, porque
precisamente no queremos ser, digamos
como obtusos en pensar que solamente
nosotros debemos ser una empresa
innovadora y que aporte al desarrollo
social de Colombia, sino que buscamos
que ojalá todas las empresas de Colombia
sean innovadoras, que todas las empresas
de Colombia y todas las cajas de
compensación en particular tengan un
portafolio de servicios que logre
efectivamente impactar las necesidades
de esos trabajadores que hay a lo largo
y ancho del país. ¿Y por qué decimos
esto? Porque hoy en día la normatividad
del subsidio familiar hace que uno
solamente pueda afiliar empresas de la
región donde hacemos presencia.
Entonces, con subsidio afilia hoy en día
empresas de Bogotá y Cundinamarca y
hacia ellos es donde focalizamos
nuestros esfuerzos. Y si bien es cierto
tenemos una presencia a nivel nacional,
esa presencia está eh principalmente en
programas orientados a los temas de
salud con esas dos vertientes, atención
en salud o dispensación de medicamentos,
que ustedes saben eh la gran mayoría de
los que están acá, que son unos temas
que hoy en día el país necesita
muchísima participación y muchísimos
aliados para sacar adelante estas
iniciativas. Bueno, ese eh cierre de
brechas sociales siempre se hace,
digamos, como con tres ejes importantes
que están allá y es particularmente
siempre estar en función del cliente,
siempre trabajar muchísimo todo lo que
es ese tema de trabajadores afiliados,
porque de alguna manera cuando uno mira
las necesidades de la empresa, del
trabajador, de la familia, de los
usuarios que tenemos en los diferentes
servicios y programas, hacia ellos nos
debemos y para ellos es que trabajamos,
estudiamos detenidamente sus
características, sus tipologías.
Organizamos diferentes segmentos de
clientes para los cuales trabajamos y a
cada uno de ellos buscamos identificar
precisamente lo que les duele, lo que
necesitan y ahí entramos nosotros como
corporación a entender esas necesidades
y ante todo a proponerles soluciones
potentes y soluciones innovadoras.
Internamente, las personas que
trabajamos en esta institución nos
caracterizamos por cuatro grandes
valores. Por un lado, la excelencia en
lo que hacemos. El segundo valor
importante es la pasión por servir.
Reconocer que nuestra labor está
construyendo un mejor país, ayuda a
mejor a mejorar calidad de vida de las
personas y de sus familias. tenemos un
compromiso eh social importantísimo
porque sabemos que con nuestros
portafolios y con nuestras actividades
estamos de alguna de alguna manera
abriendo posibilidades de desarrollo de
las personas y de sus familias. Y
también trabajamos un cuarto ahora es la
importancia de la integridad, el manejar
con total transparencia, con muchísima
eficiencia todo lo que estamos haciendo.
Y a nivel más externo, en este círculo,
manejamos muchísimo todo lo que son
temas digitales, porque somos
conscientes que el mundo cambió. El
mundo se transformó y las tecnologías
digitales abarcan hoy en día todas las
facetas de la vida y por eso estamos
metidos ahí. De igual manera también
buscamos ser una organización ágil, una
organización que efectivamente hablamos
mucho desde nuestras realizaciones y
desde nuestros proyectos implementados.
Aquí no basta con tener buenas ideas.
Para transformar el país, necesitamos es
tener acciones concretas, específicas,
que impacten muchísimo la calidad de
vida de esta cantidad de trabajadores
que están vinculados con nosotros. Y
finalmente, lo que estamos también
buscando es generarle a esa cantidad de
personas que están vinculadas con
nosotros esas experiencias positivas,
experiencias memorables que les ayuden a
cambiar su percepción de vida y ante
todo a seguir mejorando eh esa calidad
de vida tanto de las personas a manera
individual como de los grupos
familiares.
¿Cómo hacemos esto? Este perfil
organizacional abarca que la esencia
nuestra es ofrecer programas en el marco
de la protección social, como se los
decía en un comienzo. Y desde ahí es que
surge nuestro énfasis en tener programas
educativos, en tener muchos programas
que están orientados a fortalecer la
productividad de las empresas, porque si
las empresas son más productivas crecen
y si crecen generan empleo y si generan
empleo este país va a ser más próspero.
Pero también trabajamos en temas
culturales porque indudablemente la
educación y la cultura juntos nos
potencian para obtener no solamente
desarrollo económico, sino verdadero
desarrollo social. De igual manera,
trabajamos para entregar viviendas a
esos eh trabajadores colombianos en
desarrollar una infinidad de programas
de recreación, deportes, de evento, de
actividades turísticas, de trabajarle
muchísimo también a todo lo que tiene
que ver con programas de crédito y
acceso a financiamiento para los
trabajadores de más bajos ingresos,
hacer también programas de seguros para
ellos y, ¿por qué no? También decir la
importancia de ofrecer programas de
alimentos y bebidas para las empresas,
para las personas con una red de
restaurantes que tenemos en los
programas de salud con todo lo que es el
tema de atención en salud y también la
dispensación de medicamentos, viendo
esto de una manera muy integral.
Entonces, como ustedes ven, todas estas
líneas de trabajo que nosotros tenemos,
en cada de unas hay inmensos retos y
oportunidades.
Siempre comparto por Facebook y digo,
con subsidio es una organización de
grandes números y si yo les contara a
ustedes que, por ejemplo, tenemos 42
millones de transacciones en
medicamentos, 22 millones de
transacciones en salud anualmente y si
me fuera por cada uno de los elementos
de este círculo que les estoy mostrando
acá, indudablemente somos una
organización de grandes proyecciones, de
grandes números, pero de igual manera de
grandes oportunidades para identificar
temas en los que queremos mejorar y
vincularlos a muchos de ustedes para que
nos ayuden a encontrar esas mejoras.
resoluciones y de manera complementaria
tenemos una participación de una serie
de empresas eh que están articuladas en
con los temas de la seguridad social en
dos EPS como Famisanar y Nueva eh Nueva
EPS y Famisanar en el Fondo de Pensiones
Protección en Simple, que es un operador
de información en Aulado, que es otra
entidad de programas sociales y
finalmente de la TEC Alianza, que es un
programa educativo que estamos
justamente potenciando en concurso y
alianza con la universidad de los Andis.
Entonces, como ustedes pueden ver, esto
es lo que hace con subsidio y yo reitero
muy desde la acción, muy desde diseñar e
implementar programas que impacten
calidad de vida de las personas. ¿Listo?
Sigamos.
Con todo este contexto les quiero decir
que básicamente, como les decía en la
introducción, nosotros creemos en los
procesos de innovación abierta porque
somos conscientes de que las
organizaciones, independientemente del
tamaño que tengamos, siempre vamos a
estar necesitando ideas nuevas, ideas
retadoras y tarde que temprano las
personas que nos vinculamos a una
organización terminamos eh siendo
permeados por un tema que se habla mucho
en los círculos de innovación es como
las culturas corporativas empiezan
incluso también a permear y a sesgar la
innovación. Hm. Y entonces aquí es donde
cobra especial relevancia que uno
empiece a identificar actores externos
que pueden generarle muchísima potencia
a la innovación interna nuestra,
generando, ¿qué? alternativas, haciendo
las cosas mucho más rápidas, trayéndonos
nuevas metodologías, nuevas formas de
enseñar todo lo que estamos haciendo y
particularmente nosotros como
organización, si aquí esta gráfica eh
que está en azul, lo que potenciamos es
un poco nuestras posiciones que hemos
venido desarrollando en el ranking
nacional de innovación acá en Colombia.
Ese es un ranking de innovación que
empezó hace ya 10 años. Nosotros hemos
participado en las últimas nueve
ediciones y realmente hemos venido
precisamente trabajando por innovar en
servicios, en procesos, en portafolios,
en mejorar eficiencias internas. Y a
partir de todo eso, en la medida en que
vamos identificando temas y que a cada
uno de estos temas identificados le
generamos propuestas innovadoras, nos
damos cuenta que innovar vale la pena. Y
cada vez también nos damos más cuenta
que cuando innovamos con terceros las
cosas funcionan mejor, que
indudablemente implica trabajar
conjuntamente, ponernos de acuerdo,
tener conversaciones iniciales, pero
ante todo construir conjuntamente y eso
agrega muchísimo a estos ejercicios.
Como ustedes pueden ver, nosotros en
esta evolución del ranking de
innovación, eh justamente desde los
últimos 5 años estamos entre las 30
empresas más innovadas de este país y
esto es algo de profundo orgullo y
alegría, pero créanme que no lo hemos
construido solos, lo hemos construido
con una cantidad de actores del
ecosistema de innovación que han
participado y que han sumado esfuerzos
con nosotros para encontrar de verdad
iniciativas potentes, diferentes y eso
es lo que nos ha llevado donde estamos
hace un año. año éramos la empresa
número uno de innovación de este país.
Este año estamos en el puesto número
seis y de alguna manera, insisto, lo que
nosotros buscamos con esto es reconocer
que todo lo que hace historia en el
mundo nació justamente de una idea,
nació de alguien que decidió innovar y
que innovar a veces no es fácil, a veces
hay que romper paradigmas, a veces hay
que llevar la contraria, a veces hay que
efectivamente tener la persistencia para
converser a los demás de las ideas de
uno. Pero cuando uno lo logra
efectivamente los resultados son
potentes. Entonces nuestra invitación es
a que efectivamente nosotros somos una
organización de grandes proporciones,
que aquí vamos a trabajar cuatro retos
que ya más adelante Andrea de nuestro
equipo de innovación se los va a
compartir, pero que ante todos somos
unos convencidos de que si los
trabajamos con todos ustedes vamos a
encontrar soluciones potentes. Y además
con una particularidad, esto no se trata
de hacer presentaciones teóricas, vamos
a hacer implementaciones reales de las
soluciones potentes y ese es el gran
reto para todos los que están acá.
Sigamos, Sandra.
Bueno, un poco en estos temas, como les
explicaba anteriormente, esa cobertura
que geográfica que nosotros tenemos a
nivel nacional eh en esos eh
departamentos, en esos 60 municipios de
Cundinamarca, en esas 280 y pico de
sedes a nivel de Bogotá implican tener
un equipo de trabajo potente, que somos
algo así como 15,900 trabajadores. Y
esos 15900 trabajadores, estamos
trabajando, por ejemplo, en salud
tenemos 8800 trabajadores. En el área de
vivienda hay 158 trabajadores. En las
gerencias de recreación y de deporte son
casi 800 personas que están ahí. En
educación 2,787.
En hotelería, más de 1000. 416 personas
en el área de alimentos y bebidas. en el
área de créditos trabajan 159 personas y
de manera complementaria a nivel
administrativo y de soporte para toda la
organización tenemos otras casi 100
personas. Entonces, como ustedes pueden
ver, este es un equipo de personas que
cada una de ellas tiene un rol, tiene
una capacidad, tiene unas habilidades,
tiene unas profesiones. Y yo los invito
a que ustedes piensen en algo. Cada una
de las operaciones es un mundo
diferente. Es totalmente diferente
trabajar los temas de vivienda que
trabajar los temas de crédito. Es
totalmente diferente pensar en los temas
de crédito que estar pensando en los
programas de hotelería. Y así como es un
mundo la hotelería, también es otro
mundo, el de los seguros. Y en cada una
de estas áreas tenemos, insisto, muchas
oportunidades y temas que queremos
trabajar, pero que sabemos que con
ustedes podemos encontrar soluciones más
rápidas, más potentes y de alguna manera
también mucho más funcionales para
todos. Entonces, esa es la invitación
que estamos haciendo. Dale, Sandro.
Y precisamente lo que estamos buscando
acá es que nosotros somos una
organización, como les decía, de
1,473,000
trabajadores afiliados a diciembre. Esa
cifra hoy en día ya está rondando
elillón y medio y particularmente 96,423
empresas afiliadas. Hoy ya estamos
llegando a los 100,000. En materia de
ingresos, esta es una empresa de 6,6
billones de pesos en ingresos,
8.3 3 billones en activos y 3,4 billones
de pesos en lo que es un patrimonio.
Todo esto lo hemos logrado gracias a
excelencia, a muchísimo esfuerzo, de
controlar todo lo que estamos haciendo
en materia de eficiencias, de controles
internos, pero ante todo insisto en
tener como foco claro que trabajamos es
para millones de colombianos que
necesitan de nuestra presencia y
necesitan ante todo de oferta de
servicios y programas sociales que le
satisfagan su nivel de vida. Entonces,
eso es lo que hacemos acá. Sigamos.
Todo este ejercicio y toda esta dinámica
y todos estos 69 años de vida que
cumplimos justamente ahorita en
septiembre, eh nos tienen posicionados
con una serie de actividades y de
eventos que para nosotros lo más
orgulloso es que no somos nosotros los
que lo decimos, sino que son
instituciones externas las que nos
reconocen. Entonces, como les decíamos,
sexto puesto en el ranking nacional de
innovación, puesto número uno en todo lo
que es inversión social y ambiental
privada en Colombia. Somos la empresa
número nueve en cantidad de número
trabajadores. Somos la empresa número 23
con mayores ingresos según la revista
Semana. Son la empresa número 20 entre
las empresas más queridas por todos los
colombianos. Somos la empresa número 28
en los medidores de sostenibilidad de
una empresa española que se llama Merco.
Somos la empresa número 31 a nivel
nacional en otras indicadores de esta
misma empresa española que mide
precisamente el talento humano y el
grado de aceptación de las empresas por
sus trabajadores. Somos la empresa
número 39 en esas eh entidades que miden
también la reputación por esta empresa
Merco como empresas y somos número 48
con nuestro director general, Dr. Luis
Carlos Arango Vélez como el líder eh de
entre número 48 entre los líderes
empresariales más significativos de
Colombia. Esto se logra precisamente con
el trabajo, el esfuerzo y la dedicación
de esos casi 16,000 trabajadores que
estamos aquí todos los días, insisto,
entendiendo necesidades de nuestros
clientes, pero ante todo generando
oportunidades para satisfacer esas
necesidades de empresas afiliadas, de
sus trabajadores y de esas familias
vinculadas con nosotros. Ese es el gran
reto de lo que nosotros estamos buscando
aquí día tras día. sigamos.
Y entonces, ¿qué es lo que estamos
haciendo acá? Precisamente reconocer que
con innovación abierta podemos hacer
cosas diferentes, que con innovación
abierta y con la participación de todos
los que están acá vamos a enriquecer
esas ideas que tenemos. Vamos a
complementar el conocimiento que
nosotros tenemos de nuestro cliente con
el conocimiento que ustedes tienen de
nuevas tecnologías y de nuevas formas de
hacer las cosas. Si nos unimos, si
trabajamos como equipo, si definimos que
los objetivos de ustedes y nuestros son
comunes, les aseguro que vamos a generar
soluciones que van a impactar la vida de
millones de colombianos. Y para hacerlo
dijimos, necesitamos tener un aliado
importante y lo hablábamos con Sandra en
alguna oportunidad y necesitamos aliados
que precisamente nos permitan
conectarnos con muchas startups, no
solamente en Colombia, sino a nivel
latinoamericano, que tenemos problemas
relativamente similares, pero que ante
todo tenemos el talento, la pasión y el
compromiso de ayudar a construir mejores
países y mejores sociedades en las que
estamos trabajando acá en Colombia y
Latinoamérica. Y por eso dijimos, el
aliado tiene que ser 30x. Y yo ahí,
Sandra, ya los dejo descansar a todos de
mi voz y los dejo contigo para que tú
nos cuentes que es 30x.
Buenísimo. Gracias, Juan Manuel.
Espectacular tu introducción a Col
subsidio. Me encanta. Y para mí, que he
estado en muchos hackatons en los
últimos años, eh puedo decir que en los
últimos 5 años he participado en más de
10, 15 hackatons en los que en algunos
he ganado, en algunos he estado como
mentora, en algunos he estado como
organizadora.
La es la primera vez que llego a
encontrar a una compañía de la magnitud
o una empresa de la magnitud como es col
subsidio participar en este tipo de eh
de este tipo de iniciativas. Así que
para mí es un gran orgullo poder
participar en conjunto. Muchos de
ustedes ya puede que ya conozcan un poco
de 30x, eh, sin embargo, les voy a
comentar rápidamente pues qué somos.
Nosotros somos actualmente la plataforma
que ofrece la mejor educación ejecutiva
en inteligencia artificial para
Latinoamérica. Esto quiere decir que no
solamente lo hacemos dentro de Colombia,
sino lo hacemos para cualquier país de
Latinoamérica de forma online. En su
mayoría en la gran mayoría de nuestros
programas, nosotros podemos formar a
ejecutivos, desarrolladores y equipos
comerciales para que lleven la
inteligencia artificial de la teoría a
la práctica con proyectos reales como
los que vamos a construir durante este
hackatom. Nosotros normalmente lo que
hacemos es justamente tener muchas
clases gratuitas y tenemos unos
programas que duran entre dos a tro
semanas. Eh, y directamente ahí les
estamos comentando a o los estamos
formando a ejecutivos, sobre todo a los
líderes de equipos, a cómo poder
implementar la inteligencia artificial.
Entonces pasamos de hm me llama la
atención esta tecnología a cómo hago que
esto baje desde no solamente la idea de
hay que hacerlo a realmente el equipo ya
lo lo puede hacer. Y nosotros comenzamos
con justamente los ejecutivos o las
cabezas de estos equipos, porque sabemos
que si tienes 100 personas en tu equipo
y resulta que esas 100 personas, 99
están seguros de queríamos utilizar
inteligencia artificial, pero uno y
justamente ese uno puede ser el CEO, el
líder o el dueño del negocio, no está de
acuerdo, pues simplemente no va a pasar.
Así que por eso nos enfocamos justamente
en siempre eh comenzar por esa cabeza
para que todo eso baje y los otros
equipos adopten tecnología. Incluso
muchas personas que van a programas como
el inmersivo eh presencial ejecutivo o
eh AI for Executives, donde enseñamos
justamente a los líderes o los Levels,
después terminan trayendo a todos sus
equipos a los diferentes programas que
se enfocan en otros tipos de áreas.
Ejemplo, desarrolladores,
ejemplo eh para la parte de ventas,
ejemplo, dentro de poco ya tenemos un
programa de Instagram y TikTok. Todo
esto terminan ellos trayendo su propio
equipo porque ya quieren que ellos
también aprendan a hacerlo directamente
en su área. Así que para nosotros es un
orgullo poder hoy hacer partnership o
hacer esta alianza directamente con Col
Subsidio porque es justamente resultado
de toda esta educación que hemos vivido
junto a Col Subsidio, que justamente
también es parte de nuestros clientes
principales y justo por tenerlos a ellos
ya convencidos de que la inteligencia
artificial es una tecnología que tienen
que implementar y que han comenzado a
implementar gracias a nuestros programas
también directamente ellos pues dijeron
Vamos a hacer una una hacaton donde
podamos tener muchísimas personas dentro
de Colombia y fuera de Colombia que
puedan aportar a con sus ideas a nuestro
equipo. Entonces este hacaton no
solamente enriquece a Col subsidio, sino
que también va a enriquecer a toda
nuestra red de profesionales. Tenemos
más de 4,000 líderes que han sido
capacitados, que entienden de
inteligencia artificial y que pueden
conectar con el talento que hoy forma
parte de este jacaton. Lo que queremos
es que ustedes el día de mañana ya van a
formar parte o desde hoy, digamos, ya
forman parte de nuestra red de
profesionales. Y cuando el día de mañana
a mí una empresa me dice, "Sandra,
necesito a un ingeniero que sea AI first
o necesito a una persona de marketing
que sea AI first o cualquier otro tipo
de perfil que esté dentro de nuestro
hackaton, yo puedo voltearme y buscar mi
base de datos del hackaton y decir, "Te
tengo a la persona indicada porque ya
vimos que puede construir un proyecto."
Aquí tenemos, en este caso, vamos a
poder mostrarles incluso el proyecto que
crearon para el hackaton y de una
decirle esta persona te puedo comprobar
que es AI first o que usa inteligencia
artificial para construir porque mira lo
que construyó con nosotros. Entonces,
esto, este jacaton enriquece a nuestra
red y adicionalmente queremos que
ustedes se vean enriquecidos también
desde ese sentido para que vean que van
a ser parte de esa red de profesionales
donde vamos a poder hacerles matching
con oportunidades laborales. puede que
incluso les mande o les mandemos en
algún momento un correo con ofertas
laborales y tal vez ustedes no lo estén
buscando, pero abre el correo y
encuentran su próxima gran oportunidad y
eso es lo que nosotros queremos crear
con este hackaton también, que ustedes
tengan una oportunidad de seguir
creciendo con sus habilidades
tecnológicas. Ahora bien, ¿qué tenemos
adicional dentro de 30x? Tenemos una
comunidad para prácticamente por
vertical. Tenemos comunidades, tenemos
una comunidad para ejecutivos, una
comunidad para desarrolladores, para
equipos comerciales. También subamos
hace poco una comunidad para personas
que están creando su startup y pues
quieren levantar fondos y demás. Así que
ustedes si tienen alguna pregunta sobre
estas comunidades, pueden escribirnos
dentro del grupo de WhatsApp del Hakatop
y nosotros le vamos a mandar pues toda
la información para que directo puedan
unirse a la comunidad que que sea de su
preferencia. Y lo más importante de esto
es que en todas nuestras sesiones, tanto
las gratuitas que estamos haciendo
semana a semana, por ejemplo, ayer
tuvimos una sesión sobre LinkedIn, cómo
vender por LinkedIn, que yo sabía que
eso se podía hacer y resulta que es s
super eh sereficiente y tenemos a los
mejores mentores para aprender.
Justamente ayer tuvimos, ah no, ayer fue
de Second Brain, ayer fue de cómo crear
tu segundo cerebro, pero la semana
pasada fue de AI de ventas por Linked.
Entonces, todas las semanas tenemos
estas clases gratuitas y ustedes dentro
del canal de YouTube de 30x van a poder
conseguir todas esas clases y van a
aprender construyendo, van a aprender no
solamente viendo las charlas, sino
literar llevándose promps, llevándose
skills directamente, tanto de forma
gratuita como también cuando pagan un
programa. Resulta resulta que justo van
a aprender muchísimo más porque digamos
que las clases gratuitas son como ese
pequeño bocado y ya después tienen pues
toda la posibilidad de aprender
directamente con los mentores recibiendo
ese feedback directo. Eso va a ser
espectacular. Tenemos programas, como
les comentaba, para todo tipo de
perfiles. Obviamente para la mayoría de
los que están acá. Los programas que más
les puede interesar son justamente los
que son de marketing, los que son de
desarrollo y allí tenemos una variedad
bien importante y por supuesto si están
creando su propia startup les recomiendo
el de Fun Racing School que también es
parte de nuestros programas y nosotros
pues le garantizamos, como les digo, eh
en este caso para el hackaton vamos a
traer un poco de todo eso que
normalmente tenemos en estos programas
que son mentores, mucha información,
muchísima, muchísimo contenido, pero
sobre todo contenido aplicable. Lo vamos
a traer durante este hackaton donde
ustedes van a tener mentores y talleres
durante los cinco días del evento,
bueno, realmente los primeros cuatro
para que el último día se enfoquen en
subir su proyecto y ustedes van a poder
hacerle preguntas a todos nuestros
mentores. Por ejemplo, yo voy a estar
también acompañándolos como mentora
directamente para guiarles en las ideas
que tienen y poder casarlas con los
retos de del hackatom, que ahorita ya
Andrea nos lo va a presentar. Entonces
sí durante estos 5 días ustedes van a
recibir una probada de los sí de toda la
educación que nosotros estamos buscando
que tengan nuestros nuestros alumnis o
nuestros alumnos de 30x directamente
encapsulado en eh encapsulado en esta en
estos 5 días. Dice Luis Guillermo que no
ve los videos de las clases que comento.
Eh, ahorita después les paso el link
donde estamos subiendo las últimas
clases. De igual forma estamos creo que
migrando directamente al perfil de
Andrés Bilbao y ahí es donde pueden
conseguir el último la última clase de
ayer. A ver, entonces, ¿por qué un
hackaton? ¿Por qué hemos decidido hacer
esto? Y aquí quiero hacer mucho énfasis
en eh de nuevo agradecer a Cor subsidio
por esta oportunidad de construir en
conjunto, porque realmente es muy poco
muy poco común que empresas grandes o
tan grandes como Col Subsidio justamente
vengan y sean partes de este tipo de de
eh eventos. ¿Por qué? No porque no sea
un evento, no sean estos eventos
positivos, sino que muchas empresas
sigue cierran la innovación, dicen,
"Bueno, nosotros queremos ser
innovadores, pero va a ser innovador con
mi equipo de tecnología, va a ser mi
innovador con mi equipo de negocio, con
mi equipo primero, en vez de abrirse y
comenzar a ver que la innovación también
tiene otra perspectiva que es la
innovación abierta. ¿Por qué es
importante esta esta innovación abierta?
Porque no esto no solamente vive dentro
de una empresa. Quienes vienen desde
afuera pueden traer perspectivas sin
sesgos internos, sin decir, "No, porque
es que nunca lo hemos hecho. Yo no sé si
ustedes han trabajado en grandes
corporaciones, a mí me pasó eh por mucho
tiempo en una donde estuve, que yo
quería hacer cambios en algunos procesos
y me decían, "No, es que eso siempre se
ha hecho de esa manera." Cuando uno trae
personas con una perspectiva diferente o
una mirada fresca, justamente dicen,
"Ey, pero ¿por qué no lo cambiamos? ¿Por
qué no traemos esto nuevo? Y allí es
donde esa mirada fresca puede ayudarnos
a básicamente resolver problemas que
capaz tienen años en una empresa y
resulta que con una mirada fresca ya
tenemos la solución. Pero también
tenemos velocidad en este tipo de en
este tipo de de eventos, porque en 5
días vamos a explorar caminos que
normalmente toman meses a equipos
internos en descubrir porque siempre hay
algo que es más urgente eh dentro de las
empresas normalmente. Entonces, ustedes
van a venir acá con sus miradas frescas
y con la velocidad de vamos a intentar
en 5 días resolver este reto de esta
manera y sobre todo lo más importante es
el talento nuevo. Nosotros queremos que
ustedes también puedan hacer matching o
puedan enlazarse a posibilidades y
oportunidades de trabajo directamente
con Col Subsidio. Ustedes pueden conocer
ahora que con subsidio no es solamente
una droguería o es solamente unos
hoteles, sino que ya vieron con Juan
Manuel todo lo que está detrás y todas
las oportunidades donde ustedes también
pueden crecer, incluso ya están viendo
que tienen un equipo de innovación
específicamente, así que directamente
pueden pensar, "Oye, me encantaría en
algún momento trabajar con Juan Manuel y
Andrea y por qué no se puede podría
pasar si justamente en el futuro ellos
están buscando a alguien, podrían
voltear y ver justamente a una de los
participantes que está dentro de este
hackaton. Así que justo por eso estamos
haciendo este hackaton, porque queremos
traer a cor subsidio, mirada frescas,
velocidad en esas en esas soluciones y
talento nuevo que pueda nutrir a una
empresa tan maravillosa como Col
Subsidio. Por eso estamos uniendo estos
estos esfuerzos para abrir sus retos
actuales a la comunidad de 30x y la
comunidad global y con ustedes estamos
seguros de que lo vamos a lograr. Y
justamente hablando de retos, ahí quiero
darle la palabra a Andrea, que es parte
del equipo de Col Subsidio y nos va a
contar un poco sobre estos retos que
tenemos. Tenemos cuatro retos, Andrea,
que nos habíamos comprometido con tres y
después nos volvimos locos y dijimos,
"Vamos a hacer cuatro mejor."
Sí, síos de ellos.
Muchas, muchas gracias. Bueno, entonces
les quería contar que desde col subsidio
tenemos cuatro retos que queremos
trabajar con ustedes. Les voy a contar a
grandes rasgos de que se trata cada uno
de ellos, pero en la tarde van a tener
sesiones especializadas con los gerentes
de cada una de estas áreas para que en
15 minutos les puedan contar sobre el
reto y ustedes también pues tengan la
sesión de preguntas. Entonces, les voy a
contar sobre el primer reto. Nuestro
primer reto se llama el reto de
hotelería, es optimizar la operación.
¿Qué es lo que pasa? Necesitamos lograr
que el conteo del inventario que llegue
a nuestro sistema llegue la forma más
limpia y más óptima, que no existan
errores de digitalización. Ya más
adelante les voy a contar de qué se
trata. El segundo reto es el reto de
crédito. Es un crédito
hiperpersonalizado.
Es convertir el conocimiento del
afiliado, todo lo que nosotros desde
desde Col subsidio conocemos de nuestro
afiliado para darle la mejor oferta a
este afiliado. El tercer reto es el reto
de seguros. Es la venta automatizada de
seguros. es llevar una persona desde que
tiene ese deseo de tener un seguro hasta
que realmente lo tenga ya y pues pueda
hacer uso de él. Y el último reto es el
reto de vivienda, es el perfilamiento
inteligente elite. Acá, ¿qué es lo que
queremos? es lograr que si una persona
está deseando tener un proyecto de
vivienda, tenga todo el conocimiento,
tenga todo el perfilamiento de qué es el
proyecto y pueda adquirirlo o por lo
menos saber que todo su perfil sí
coincide con ese proyecto. Ya también
les contaré más adelante de qué se
trata. Entonces, Sandra, si quieres me
colaboras con la diapositiva de la
hotelería. Entonces, ¿de qué se trata
nuestro reto de hotelería? la
optimización de la operación. ¿Qué es lo
que pasa? En este momento nosotros
tenemos bodegas en col subsidio donde va
una persona y cuenta manualmente, bueno,
cuenta eh los productos que existen en
esta bodega. Acá tenemos un reto
importante y es que al momento de
pasarlo, pues se pasa muy manualmente.
Entonces, no sé, se dice 9 libras, si
eran 90 libras y se pasa ese dato al
sistema con este error. ¿Qué es lo que
estamos buscando o cuál es la misión? es
quitarle esa fricción y el error al
momento de digitalizar, entonces que
realmente salga de forma limpia.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo que les proponemos
o queremos de ustedes? Que nos ayuden a
buscar la solución para que este
problema digitalización ya no exista,
sino se pueda hacer de pronto de otra
forma y que realmente lo que vea la
persona pues sí que en el sistema.
Entonces, estamos buscando desde un
agente por voz que capture los pedidos
hasta un sistema integral que valide las
recetas históricos y bueno y todo lo que
se incluya allí.
Vamos con el siguiente reto.
Igual tranquilo, si tienen preguntas y
les interesa mucho este reto, vamos a
tener una sesión explícita para este
reto. Vamos con el segundo reto. El reto
de créditos es el crédito
hiperpersonalizado.
Ustedes saben que como somos una caja de
compensación, col subsidio conoce muchos
sus afiliados. sabe dónde trabaja, qué
servicios usa, qué eventos de vida ha
atravesado, pero tenemos un reto que nos
gustaría afrontar con ustedes y es saber
qué oferta de crédito darle a estas
personas, qué producto le puede servir,
cuál es el monto, cuál es el mensaje
genérico que les debemos dar. Entonces,
¿cuál es nuestra misión? es convertir
todo el conocimiento que nosotros ya
tenemos de nuestros afiliados para poder
darles una razón clara y un lenguaje
natural de por qué la oferta de crédito
que les estamos ofreciendo es la ideal
para ellos. Entonces, ¿qué buscamos?
Desde un motor de segmentación
inteligente hasta un sistema que decida
qué ofrecer, cuándo ofrecer y por qué
ofrecer este servicio.
Vamos con el siguiente. El tercero es la
venta de seguros. Entonces es la venta
automatizada de seguros. Hoy adquirir un
seguro, ustedes saben que requiere que
se conten con una asesora, contarle
sobre todo el portafolio que tenemos,
que se explique y se cierre. Eso no es
escalable y pues ustedes saben que no es
247 o debería funcionar 247, pero pues
en este momento no funciona 247 y
depende pues siempre de una persona que
esté ahí disponible para contestar todas
estas dudas. ¿Qué es lo que estamos
buscando desde col subsidio? eh dejar
este intermedario y buscar una
plataforma, un sistema, algo que nos
ayude a que las personas puedan adquirir
estos seguros de forma automatizada.
Entonces, ¿qué buscamos desde un
cotizador inteligente que le ayude a la
persona a a saber cuál es el seguro
ideal para él? hasta un flujo completo
que decida el momento y presente la
oferta y cierre la venta. Muy importante
que busquemos cómo se haga todo este
flujo de inicio a fin y se cierre la
venta.
Y vamos con nuestro último reto. El reto
de vivienda es el perfilamiento
inteligente de LS. ¿Qué es lo que pasa?
Desde la pauta digital que tenemos en
este momento, miles de personas están
interesadas en diferentes proyectos,
pero ustedes saben que tenemos
diferentes segmentaciones o que hay
diferentes tipos de proyectos para
diferentes tipos de personas. Entonces,
lo que estamos buscando es que exista un
embudo donde se pueda decir, este
proyecto le sirve a esta persona y por
eso te lo ofrezco a ti. Entonces, lograr
que estos lead de pautas se parezcan a
lo más orgánicos posibles, que estén
perfilados y que se entiendan con el
proyecto para que el para que el asesor
pues el último asesor pueda conversar
con esta persona y hacer la venta.
Entonces, no mostrarles muchos, muchos
portafolios o proyectos, sino que el
proyecto que sea para ti te funcione.
Nosotros igual te vamos a dar esta
información, cuáles son los proyectos,
cuánto cuestan y todo lo necesario para
que podamos hacer este match entre el el
proyecto y las personas. Entonces, ¿qué
buscamos? Desde un perfilador
conversacional que valí la capacidad de
compra hasta un sistema que califique,
nutra y priorice cada ladit. Importante
decirles, en este momento nosotros
tenemos un WhatsApp donde se ponen los
portafolios y las personas van
escribiendo, pero no alcanza hacer el
match necesario para realmente tener la
venta y pues que las personas se sientan
satisfechas con el servicio. Entonces,
eso es lo que estamos buscando, cómo le
hacemos más fácil la vida a nuestros
afiliados. Y listo, esos son los cuatro
retos. Recuerden que igual en la tarde
vamos a tener una sesión para contarles
bien los retos, ustedes puedan tener
todas las preguntas y resolverles estas
dudas. Muchas gracias, Sandra.
Maravilloso, Andrea. Muchísimas gracias
por comentarnos todo sobre estos retos.
Bueno, este primer abrebocas ya a partir
de la tarde vamos a tener esos sí, esas
esas sesiones mucho más dedicadas, media
hora a cada reto. Directamente ya pueden
ya pueden ver en el cronograma a qué
hora van a ser las sesiones. Vamos a
tener una que en horario colombiano va a
comenzar a las 2, que es sobre reto
crédito. Después vamos a tener sobre
reto hotelería, reto seguros y reto
vivienda. Entonces, voy a dedicarme
ahorita a hablarles un poquito sobre las
reglas y entregables que vamos a tener y
pueden ir dejando sus preguntas ya
directamente en nuestras eh sí, en los
comentarios de YouTube que yo voy a ver
todas y además vamos a responder todas
las que se puedan y las que no se puedan
durante esta sesión vamos a poder
responderlas directamente en el
WhatsApp. Entonces, esos son los cuatro
retos. Entiendo que acá durante esta
presentación pusimos el reto de
hotelería de primero, pero no es como
que existe un reto uno, un reto dos o
reto tres o cuatro. Literalmente los
retos eh van a lo la forma de
organizarlos es simplemente por nombre.
Entonces, el reto de crédito siempre
hace reto de crédito. En algunos
momentos vamos a ponerlo o mencionarlo
como reto o el primer reto, después como
reto dos o algo así, pero lo importante
es que ustedes se queden con reto de
crédito. Es reto de crédito, no es reto
uno, es crédito y reto dos es tal. sino
solamente por nombre. Ahora, eh vamos a
pasar un poco a contarles cuáles son las
reglas y entregables que vamos a tener
durante este hackatom. Lo primero es que
ustedes van a subir eh su demo funcional
de la solución. Necesitamos que eso esté
en algún link donde las personas que
vamos a evaluar estos retos eh digo,
estos proyectos, vamos a poder hacer
clic y ver que en efecto funciona.
Después de eso, también necesitamos que
nos entreguen un pit y demo de 2
minutos. Y acá entro a contarles un
poquito de qué significa eso. Va a ser
básicamente van a tener 2 minutos eh o
su o su pit o demo debe ser de 2 minutos
donde ustedes puedan explicar el
problema solución demo y el impacto de
esta solución que están creando. ¿Por
qué 2 minutos? Yo sé que para muchas
personas 2 minutos puede parecer s super
largo, pero o mejor dicho supercorto,
pero en realidad eh necesitamos que
ustedes puedan explicar la solución en
poco tiempo, porque eso también les va a
enseñar a ustedes a vender una solución
de forma mucho más eficiente y rápida.
Ahora bien, eh para poder aprender a
hacer estos pit.
Uno, vamos a tener una charla con Ángela
Ocando, que es una de nuestras mentoras,
donde les va a enseñar cómo hacer este
pit, cómo hacerlo un ganador, por así
decirlo, cómo poder mostrar este pit de
la mejor manera y adicional a eso, vamos
a tener mentorías directamente con el el
equipo de Full Racing School que nos va
a acompañar y va a poder darles a
ustedes feedback en sus pichas
directamente el sábado en la tarde. van
a estar totalmente disponibles para esto
y además van a poder agendar con uno de
los mentores que se llama Sebastián, que
es de Fund Racing School para poder
preguntarle cómo va en su pitos canales.
Igual se los vamos a enviar directamente
en el grupo de WhatsApp. Si ustedes en
este momento están acá y no están en el
grupo de WhatsApp, por favor escriban en
el en los comentarios para saber pues
cuántas personas no están aún en ese
grupo. Sin embargo, ya desde hace días,
desde ayer, estuvimos enviándoles
comunicaciones para que entren, deben
estar muy pendientes de sus correos, que
es donde estamos mandando todas las
comunicaciones principalmente. ¿Cuáles
son entonces los entregables que
necesitamos de ustedes? En este caso la
demo funcional, el link donde nosotros
podemos entrar y usar esa solución, ese
pitch o demo de 2 minutos y el
repositorio del código. Eh, este
repositorio debe ser en Ghob. ustedes
crean su repositorio, lo dejan
completamente público y lo único que
nosotros vamos a evaluar de además del
código en general, vamos a eh tener como
regla que si el repositorio fue creado
antes del día de hoy, no va a ser
evaluado. Si tiene algún comit adicional
después de las 11:30 de la mañana, hora
Colombia, del domingo 26 de julio, no va
a ser evaluado, es decir, hasta las
11:30 ustedes pueden hacer cambios. Así
que tengan muy en cuenta esa hora, el el
domingo 26 de julio, 11:30 de la mañana
va a ser el cierre de la entrega de
proyectos. ¿Ustedes van a poder
entregarlos antes? Sí, totalmente.
Nosotros vamos a abrir la plataforma
donde ustedes van a poder crear sus
grupos y entregar sus proyectos desde
mañana. No se preocupen por eso. Yo
entiendo que todos queremos de una vez
ya tener la plataforma todo listo, pero
vamos a a tenerla lista para mañana. Así
que ustedes allí van a poder crear sus
grupos y adicionalmente ir creando su
proyecto. Pero eso hoy vamos a dejarlo
tanto para que aprendamos muchísimo de
los retos como para que de una puedan eh
iniciar a integrar sus grupos y a partir
de mañana pueden pensar en bueno,
creamos el grupo dentro de la
plataforma. En la plataforma van a poder
entrar con los correos en los que con
los que ustedes se registraron. Si yo me
registré con san@gmail.com
y resulta que estoy intentando ingresar
a la plataforma con san1@gmail.com,
no voy a poder ingresar, tiene que ser
el mismo correo con el que ustedes
hicieron su inscripción, así que muy
pendientes de eso. Ahora bien, de nuevo,
el cierre de desarrollo va a ser domingo
26 de julio a las 11:30 a. De hecho,
antes iba a ser a las 11 y dimos media
hora más, así que a menos que sea un
hiper problema técnico de la plataforma,
no vamos a hacer ningún tipo de sección,
así que muy pendientes en eso.
Bien, entonces, ¿cómo se van a elegir
los ganadores? Vamos a tener tres pasos,
bueno, o dos pasos realmente vamos a
tener un prefiltro. Un equipo técnico de
jurados va a revisar todos los
proyectos. Esto va a ser un equipo de
cinco jurados internos que van a ser, no
son los jurados finales, que son los que
van a eh van a juzgar todos los primeros
o los finalistas, sino vamos a hacer un
equipo un poco más grande, creo que
vamos a hacer entre seis, siete
personas, donde allí vamos a evaluar
todos los proyectos. Todos nosotros
vamos a sentarnos y ver todos y cada uno
de los demos, todos y cada uno de sus
fiches, todos y cada uno de los
repositorios. Vamos a evaluarlo, vamos a
darle eh internamente esa esa valoración
y de ahí van a salir seis finalistas, el
mejor proyecto de cada uno de los cuatro
retos más dos de más los dos proyectos
con mejor puntaje general. Y estos seis
proyectos van a ser notificados media
hora antes de la presentación final para
que presenten su pich en vivo con los
jurados finales. Y yo sé que ya me están
preguntando por allí quiénes son los
jurados. Nosotros vamos a decirles
quiénes son los jurados. Hm.
Probablemente entre viernes y sábado.
¿Por qué? Vamos a mantenerlo en secreto
porque ahí estábamos pensando que,
bueno, a veces hay personas que van y le
escriben a los jurados. Entonces, vamos
a dejar esto como una pequeña intriga
hasta el viernes sábado que le vamos a
nombrar quiénes son los jurados, pero
les anticipo pues los jurados van a ser
mayoritariamente parte de col subsidio,
son serán las personas que h son dueños
de estos procesos y adicional a eso
tendremos jurados desde 30x. El
prefrilto lo vamos a hacer con personas
que lideran también estos procesos, pero
no son directamente h digamos gerentes o
vicepresidentes de estas áreas. Así que
eso nos va a permitir que en el pit
final ustedes se deben orientar
muchísimo, justamente mostrar en esos
minutos 2 minutos de pich y 3 minutos de
preguntas. En los 2 minutos de Pach
deben mostrar de verdad que es en vivo y
directo que su solución es la mejor y
directamente los jurados van a poder
hacerles preguntas directamente en ese
momento. Así que cualquier cosa, eso va
a ser bien interesante. Vamos a tener 3
minutos para preguntas y 2 minutos para
el pH. ¿Por qué? Eh, ¿por qué vamos a
solamente tener seis? porque bueno,
estamos estimando que van a ser una gran
cantidad de proyectos, así que solamente
para ese gran final vamos a dejar seis
que sean los mejores de todos. Ahora,
aquí me preguntan si el prefilto
solamente vamos a evaluar criterios
técnicos. Ya voy a mostrarles qué vamos
a evaluar tanto en los en el prefiltro
como en el pit final. Ahora, después de
que terminemos ese pit final, vamos a
hacer el anuncio de ganadores y
premiación. Ahora, importante tener en
cuenta el pis final no solamente es para
los equipos que estén presenciales en en
el venio o en la en el lugar
directamente acá en Bogotá en Col
subsidio La Colina, no. Vamos a tener
todos los equipos. O sea, si de repente
ustedes son, no sé, tienen un equipo
conformado por una persona de México,
una persona de Venezuela y tres personas
en Colombia, esas mismas personas que
son todas virtuales, pueden ser, van a
poder hacer su pich directamente ese
día. Así que no se preocupen. Ahora
bien, acá preguntan, según lo que dicen,
no es por cada reto que hay ganador,
¿no? Ahorita vamos a explicar eso.
Básicamente lo que vamos a tener es tres
ganadores globales que van a ser
independiente de reto y un ganador por
cada reto. Ese ganador por cada reto no
se va a llevar ningún tipo de premio
monetario, pero se va a llevar la
posibilidad de eh ser evaluado por
subsidio para la implementación. Hay
grandes posibilidades de que si ustedes
ganaron en cada uno de sus retos, pasen
a implementación directa con cubsidio.
No está completamente 100% seguro que si
ganas el reto de de seguros, valga la
redundancia, vas a implementar
directamente porque por subsidio va a
tener una entrevista con ustedes o una
reunión con ustedes como ganadores y van
a evaluar su proyecto para pasarlo
directamente a implementación. ¿Cómo se
va a hacer eso? Porque vi más temprano
que habían hecho esa pregunta. se va a
hacer eh primero pues haciendo esa
reunión de implementación, de evaluación
y después de eso se va a firmar un
contrato donde ustedes van a tener en
este caso un contrato con cor subsidio
para implementar ese proyecto. ¿Sí? Eso
es importante allí. Entonces pongan
esto. Vamos a tener cuatro proyectos que
van a pasar a esta evaluación de
implementación. uno por reto, es decir,
cada reto va a tener su ganador y
tenemos tres premios globales, que es el
que pueden ver directamente tanto en su
kit de participante que le enviamos
ayer, como también dentro de la página
principal, que son los que se van a
llevar esos premios.
Adicional a eso, las personas que o los
o los proyectos que ganen directamente
en cada uno de los retos no solamente
van a pasar a implementación con col
subsidio, sino que también se van a
llevar eh cupos dentro de nuestros
programas de 30X. Importante tener eso
en cuenta. Ahora bien, ¿cuáles son esos
criterios de evaluación? Primero, el
impacto. ¿Qué tanto va a resolver el
problema real del o qué tanto resuelve
esa solución el problema realo y cuántas
personas llega a beneficiar?
Adicional a eso, vamos a evaluar
innovación, originalidad del enfoque y
uso inteligente de la de la inteligencia
artificial. No solo inteligencia
artificial por decir hm usé inteligencia
artificial.
ejecución técnica que funcione, que
pueda tener que sea un demo sólido, que
tenga calidad en el código y que sea
viable de implementar. Es decir, si
ustedes me dicen mañana que tienen, no
sé, para el reto de hotelería, que
crearon un humanoide o desarrollaron un
robot que puede ayudar a estas personas
a hacer la captura de los datos de las
de las cosas que están llegando en el
inventario y es, no sé, por es un robot
humanoide que literalmente puede
solucionar esto. Sería genial,
espectacular. Pero, ¿qué tan viable es
que podamos repetir a ese humanoide y
podamos hacerlo en todos los en todos
los eh en todos los lugares con
subsidio, capaz es poco posible.
Entonces, piénsen la solución, cómo
puede ser también viable de ejecutar en
col subsidio general. Eso también lo
tenemos que tener en cuenta. Y la
presentación del PH en este caso acá
tengo este pequeño error de
eh de 5 minutos, pero en realidad son 2
minutos de presentación, problema,
solución, impacto en 2 minutos. Ya en el
final sí tenemos 5 minutos porque van a
ser dos de pich y tres de preguntas.
Ahora bien, importante, estos criterios
de evaluación no solamente son para el
último para el último stage o para el
último momento que es el pit final, sino
también para el prefiltro. solamente que
en este prefiltro ustedes su código y
todo va a ser va a ser visto por un
equipo de jurados que los va a revisar
al completamente. el pit final si es ya
como que prefiltrado, que si tienen
todos estos todos estos criterios
completamente genial, o sea, que están
muy bien estos estos estos proyectos y
solamente pasan a la última evaluación
donde simplemente vamos a decir, bueno,
¿quién es primer lugar, segundo lugar,
etcétera? Y tercer lugar. Ahora bien,
¿cómo se ve este hackaton? Esto me
encanta porque es un poco como para que
podamos entender qué tan grande ha sido
esta iniciativa. Somos 800 personas que
están o más de 800 personas que están
dentro de este hackaton. Si no mal
recuerdo, somos 830 y algo, 31 hasta
esta mañana a las 7:30 que cerramos eh
las inscripciones. Cerramos las
inscripciones ya hoy. Eso quiere decir
que pues simplemente nosotros ya si
ustedes se inscriben ahorita o trata de
inscribirse ahorita a las 10 de la
mañana, no van a poder hacerlo porque ya
está cerrado. Vamos a tener 150
participantes presenciales. Nosotros les
indicamos que íbamos a tener hasta 100,
pero decidimos hacer un esfuerzo
adicional para que puedan entrar hasta
50 personas más. Ya todas estas personas
tienen su aprobación, es decir, ya todas
estas personas fueron comunicadas de que
van a poder estar presencialmente, ya no
hay posibilidad de asignar un nuevo cupo
allí y vamos a tener a más de 600
participantes virtuales. Tenemos estos
cuatro cuatro retos reales y vamos a
tener esos premios generales que les
comenté. Y la oportunidad más grande es
que su solución no solamente llegue a
producción con cubsidio. Eh, la
oportunidad más grande es justamente que
su solución pueda llegar a producción
con subsidio y pueda tocar la vida de
millones de personas afiliadas. Como ya
vieron previamente te estamos hablando
de que su solución muchas veces nosotros
cuando intentamos buscar como
desarrolladores una nueva oportunidad,
etcétera, muchas veces vamos y pensamos,
bueno, eh quiero mostrarles que yo
realmente puedo construir algo
importante, algo nuevo y esta es
oportunidad para construir algo lo
suficientemente grande y bueno para que
entre a implementación con col subsidio
y el día de mañana no sea solamente un
proyecto pequeño que pueda mostrarles a
futuros clientes y demás. más, sino que
también podamos justamente mostrárselo a
cualquier eh a cualquier cliente y
decirle, "Mira, no no solamente soy yo
el que te puede decir que soy bueno
desarrollando o soy bueno en tecnología,
también lo puedes decir con subsidio.
Tuve este proyecto con ellos, impacto de
esta manera internamente. ¿Y cómo se va
a vivir la semana? Vamos a tener 5 días,
como ya saben, vamos a tener desde el
miércoles hasta el domingo totalmente
virtual o híbrido en general. Hoy vamos
a tener esta o tenemos esta ceremonia de
apertura, tenemos los retos, formación
de equipos y tenemos talleres técnicos.
Toda esta información la pueden ver
directamente en la página del hackaton.
Bajan y sale cronograma o simplemente
buscan innovación.corsubsidio.com/
eh eh cronograma y ya directamente van a
encontrar toda la información de el
cronograma actual. Eh, eso lo van a
tener completamente disponible allí. Y
ahí incluso al darle clic en donde dice
ver, van a poder encontrar directamente
cada una de las páginas donde eh van a
poder ver o los links directos para ver
estas estas presentaciones que vamos a
tener, mentorías, talleres, etcétera.
Mañana también va a ser totalmente
enfocado en talleres técnicos y
mentorías. mañana creo que nada más
tenemos dos para que realmente se
enfoquen en seguir construyendo. Después
vamos a tener desde el viernes hasta el
domingo sesiones presenciales eh y
también virtuales, pero del el viernes
va a arrancar la parte presencial. Las
personas que ya tienen las personas que
ya tienen su cupo completamente listo,
pueden ir cualquiera de los días
presencialmente. ¿Por qué les digo que
tienen que ser solo las personas que
tienen su cupo asignado? Porque nosotros
vamos a buscar a la persona en el
momento que estén llegando para poder
entregarle su escarapela, que va a tener
su nombre y apellido y necesitamos
conseguirlos en esa lista. Si no están
en la lista, lamentablemente les vamos a
pedir que se retiren, pero es s super
importante que cumplamos con de forma
muy disciplinada que cumplamos con eso,
que solamente las personas que tienen el
cupo presencial vayan de forma
presencial. Me pregunta por acá, eh,
Alejo, que si el cupo presencial, eh,
sí, que si él se inscribió para el
sábado puede ir los tres días. Sí, si tú
ya tienes todo,
si tú ya tienes todo eh tu cupo
completamente asignado, pero dijiste en
la confirmación que podías ir el domingo
nada más, pero de repente se abrió en tu
agenda más tiempo, puedes ir cualquiera
los tres días a cualquier hora. Eso va a
estar abierto de 7 de la mañana a 7 de
la noche. Así que ustedes pueden ir, no
sé, de 8 a 10, después volver de tres a
cuatro si ustedes quieren. Si nada más
quieren ir una hora, si quieren ir 3
horas, 4 horas, pueden ir en las horas
que ustedes deseen. Y también a esas
personas que van presencial, les
garantizamos eh que les vamos a dar su
almuerzo, hidratación durante todo el
día y también vamos a tener algunos
mentores allí presencial. ¿Por dónde nos
vamos a comunicar? Toda la comunicación
oficial va a pasar por nuestra comunidad
de WhatsApp. Ahí ten para hacer
preguntas de todo tipo. Si quieren hacer
una pregunta para temas presenciales,
pueden irse a la parte de presencial. Si
quieren preguntar algo sobre no tienen
equipos y quieren buscar a alguien que
se suma a su equipo, pueden hacerlo en
Busco equipo directamente. Si quieren
eh, no lo sé, preguntar algo sobre los
retos, pueden preguntarlo allí también.
Si están buscando un mentor
específicamente, pueden preguntarlo
también por allí y eh van a tener todo
el apoyo allí. En la parte de soporte,
sobre todo, lo vamos a dejar para si
ustedes tienen problemas con alguna de
nuestras plataformas. De nuevo, como les
comento, mañana le vamos a dar acceso a
la plataforma principal donde van a
tener toda la información de beneficios,
de retos, etcétera. De igual forma,
desde hoy vamos a estar
compartiéndoselas directamente tanto en
correo como en el grupo de WhatsApp. Eh,
muchas personas están preguntando,
bueno, ¿cuándo van a a pasar el tema de
los beneficios? Ya en el transcurso de
la mañana vamos a pasárselos. Igual
también están preguntando cuándo van a
obtener las bases de datos y demás de
cada reto. Se lo vamos a pasar dentro de
muy poquito directamente en el grupo de
WhatsApp y también les vamos a enviar un
correíto para que lo tengan y en la
plataforma que les vamos a dar acceso
desde mañana van a tener todo eso
viviendo en un solo lugar. Ahora bien,
charlas. Vamos a tener durante los
primeros 4 días charlas especializadas
en inteligencia artificial y negocios.
Todas disponibles desde nuestra nuestro
website y también dentro de la pl dentro
de la plataforma a la que le vamos a dar
acceso desde mañana. Así que no se
preocupen, cualquier pregunta también la
pueden hacer directamente por WhatsApp,
así no tengamos la respuesta todavía, se
las vamos a resolver lo más pronto
posible. Y ahora sí es el momento del
bombardeo. La verdad es que eh veo que
nos ha quedado bastante tiempo. Eh me
encanta porque así podemos dedicar unos
40, vamos a poner unos 30, 35 minutos a
preguntas y después de eso, si hay
alguna pregunta que quede pendiente la
pueden hacer directamente por WhatsApp.
Ahí vamos a estar. Tenemos voluntarios
que van a responder durante todo el día.
Tenemos también al parte del equipo,
somos al menos tres personas de 30x que
estamos completamente dedicadas a este
proyecto, así que ustedes pueden hacer
preguntas. También está Andrea
directamente en el WhatsApp y si tienen
alguna pregunta pueden comenzar a a
compartirla por acá. Yo trataba de
responder algunas que estaban
relacionadas a lo que estábamos
hablando, pero voy a ir revisando el los
mensajitos para ir respondiendo algunas.
Eh, la activación del kit de
participante sería el día de mañana
cuando estemos en la plataforma de
equipo. Eh, no sé a qué te refieres con
la activación del kit de participante.
Si te refieres a los beneficios o desde
hoy se lo vamos a compartir para que
todos puedan usarlo desde ya, ya, ya.
Igual de nuevo, eh, terminamos esta
ceremonia de apertura y subimos de una
la información de los retos ustedes van
a encontrar en la plataforma de
innovación eh colsubsidio.com. van a
poder encontrar la ahora en los retos
van a ver un botoncito que les va a
llevar a ver todo el reto como una
explicación más eh detallada y allí
también les va a decir, bueno, eh quiere
para que encuentren todos los recursos
de ese reto, pero denme allí una media
horita para que eso ya se vea. Pueden
ser varios repositorios para la solución
y enviar, vamos a ponerlo por acá,
pueden ser varios repositorios para la
solución y enviar la organización o
tiene que ser sí o sí un solo
repositorio. Por ejemplo, hacemos algo
en varios servicios con repos separados.
Puede ser varios repositorios, no hay
problema. Eh, lo que yo les recomendaría
es que pues prácticamente hagan un
repositorio aparte y pongan en el RMI.
Eh, sí, pongan el RMI como que aquí
puedes encontrar el fronten, aquí puedes
encontrar el backend, aquí puedes
encontrar nuestra IPI, aquí puedes
encontrar x cosa, todo lo que ustedes
consideren. Eso para tener un solo link
donde todo esté disponible.
Yo me escribí, pero no me llegó eh
ningún correo ni mensaje. ¿Qué debo
hacer? Okay, Frank, eh ta ta. Escríbenos
a hacatons aatones
@30x.
Ya te lo estoy escribiendo por acá.
escríbenos desde tu desde tu correo con
el que te inscribiste a ver qué está
pasando, buscarte porque puede ser que
hayas tenido un taipo. Nos pasó una vez
que una persona puso punto con y no
punto comom, o sea, puso punto comom con
n y no con m y eso hizo que no le
llegara ningún tipo de información.
Entonces queremos validar eso allí. Las
soluciones tienen que tener algún
institucional, colores, marcas,
etcétera, o es libre. Hm. Por ahora es
libre, pero vamos a pasarles el manual
de marca de col subsidio de una vez para
que ustedes lo tengan. Eh, lo podemos
hacer, ¿verdad, Andrea? Aquí te agrego.
Andrea, ¿podemos pasarles el el manual
de marca? Les podemos pasar el manual de
marca.
Igual lo valido y ya estaremos
conversando, ¿vale? Para pasar.
Perfecto. Gracias. Sí. Entonces, dentro
de las próximas horas le vamos a pasar
el manual de marca para que lo tengan,
eh, y ahí van a tener eh logos,
etcétera. A ver.
Hoy llega la información con la base de
datos que nos van a compartir. Sí, así
es. Eh, denme una hora máximo y ya eso
lo van a tener. Ya eso está preparado.
Solamente hay que hay que subirlo. A mí
sí me llegó, pero no puedo asistir
presencial. Entonces, otro que pueda
aprovechar el cupo. Perfecto. Eh, el
hombre gato, así se así te llamas acá.
Eh, sí, mándanos por correo eh tu
nombre, ¿no? Sí, por correo. Respóndenos
el correo donde te informamos que podías
estar presencial para saber exactamente
pues quién eres, porque el hombre gato
creo que no está registrado. Entonces,
vamos a a revisarlo. La data que nos dan
es real o simulada. Bueno, en este caso
eh hay parte real, es decir, tenemos por
ejemplo proyectos de vivienda que no son
inventados, sino son proyectos reales,
pero también tenemos data simulada, por
ejemplo, información de los afiliados,
que obviamente por por abeas data y por
el manejo correcto de la información de
las personas que son afiliadas a
corsido, no nos pueden dar la
información real, sino nos dan una
información anonimizada de esas
personas. La presentación del proyecto
se hace el domingo, asigna horarios. En
este caso, la presentación del proyecto,
eh vamos a hacer lo siguiente. A las
11:30 se va a cerrar el el sí, se va a
cerrar la entrega de los proyectos y en
ese en esa entrega de proyectos ustedes
van a poner el link de el video donde
ustedes están haciendo su demo de 2
minutos, eh demo y pH de 2 minutos.
También ahí van a subir el repositorio y
también van a subir el link directo de
donde podemos usar su MVP o su demo, es
decir, el link de la solución, el
repositorio y el video. Esas tres cosas
se entregan antes de las 11:30. A las
11:30 se cierra y ya no pueden volver a
entregarlos.
Hombre, gato, a nosotros nos interesa
ese cupón. Okay, esas tres esas tres
momentos se van a se van a hacer antes
de las 11:30. Después de eso tenemos lo
que les comentaba por acá. Tin din.
Tenemos ese prefiltro donde un grupito
nos vamos a sentar y ver cada uno de los
proyectos bien a fondo porque todos van
a ser juzgados bien a profundidad. Y
después de eso viene el pit final. media
hora antes del pit final, nosotros les
vamos a enviar un mensaje por directo,
uno a uno, y también mail a las personas
que están siendo parte de esos equipos
finalistas para que sepan a qué hora les
va a tocar hacer su pit final frente al
jurado. De nuevo, el jurado lo vamos a
estar revelando en los próximos días. A
ver,
y sí, les vamos a asignar horarios como
les comenté. Entonces, de repente te
vamos a decir, eh, sea abogados, sea
abogados, te comentamos, hola,
felicidades, estás entre los finalistas,
queremos que te presentes y te vamos a
dar esta este horario para que hagas esa
presentación. ¿Qué pasa si no no lo leen
a tiempo? Nosotros les vamos a dar unos
cuantos minutos, ponte 15 minutos para
que nos confirmen. Si no nos confirman,
pasamos al siguiente proyecto que tenga
mejor score. Así que bien pendientes
allí. Yo sé que vamos a estar
hipercsados el domingo y vamos a querer
dormir toda la mañana, pero hay que toca
estar pendiente del correíto y del
WhatsApp para que eh sepan si son
finalistas o no. Los grupos se deben ser
registrados de forma formal en algún
lado, simplemente se confirman en la
entrega de proyecto. Desde mañana van a
tener acceso a la plataforma donde
ustedes van a poder crear sus equipos y
ahí van a poder decir, por ejemplo, ¿por
qué ninguno tiene nombre? Yo quisiera
decir Andrea, pero no todos tienen unos
unos nombres raros acá. Okay. Eh, ponte
Andrés, vamos a llamarte Andrés. Eh,
Andrés resulta que tiene un equipo y
quiere eh que, por ejemplo, Fernando y
Alejandra sean parte de ese equipo.
Entonces, tú vas a poder mandarles el
correo o la invitación por correo a tu
equipo, a Alejandro y Alejandra y
Fernando, y ya los tres van a quedar en
ese equipo y ahí después van a poder
crear su proyecto directamente.
Entonces, eh por eso ayer nos
preguntaban, "¿Puedo estar en dos
equipos?" No, porque si ya Fernando está
en el equipo de Andrés, no puede estar
en el equipo de Marcos, por ejemplo.
Tiene que ser una eh un equipo por
persona básica básicamente.
Mira, hombre, gato, a esta persona le
interesa su cupo, así que avísanos quién
eres para poder brindárselo a otra
persona. ¿Qué tan dependiente puede ser
la solución a tercero? No sé exactamente
a qué te refieres en este sentido, pero
m
me imagino que te refieres a plataformas
adicionales, ¿no? Tú puedes utilizar
cualquier plataforma que necesiten, que
quieran, que se les ocurra para esta
herramienta. Incluso algo muy
importante, que sé que muchas personas
tendrán esa pregunta, puedo utilizar
inteligencia artificial para todos. Sí,
si tú quieres crear el código, crear
hasta el video del pitch, todo, todo
inteligencia artificial lo pueden hacer.
Aquí no vamos a evaluar de forma
purista, sino vamos a evaluar de la
calidad que se haga. Obviamente si haces
algo que sea todo con inteligencia
artificial y no tenga una buena calidad,
pues lamentablemente no va a quedar
entre esos finalistas, lo más probable.
Pero tal vez una persona que ni tocó una
línea de código, pero sabe hacer muy muy
buen prompting, sabe pedirle a la
inteligencia artificial exactamente que
incluso la persona ni siquiera hizo su
video, sino que lo hizo con inteligencia
artificial. Maravilloso. Esa persona
podría ganar incluso porque ha utilizado
las herramientas de la mejor forma
posible. No hay ningún tipo de de
restricción en cuanto a qué eh
herramientas pueden utilizar. solamente
pues tengan en cuenta cuáles son los
criterios de evaluación para de esa
manera tener en cuenta que si estás
utilizando algo que sea, no sé, hipercar
en un futuro, tal vez con subsidio no lo
va a implementar porque no sé, es muy
costoso, eh, incluso o es algo que no es
una herramienta tan fiable, pues tal vez
con subsidio no va a llegar a
implementarlo. Entonces, eso es
importante. Eh, ¿qué más tenemos por
acá? ¿Hay algún stack recomendado?
¿Alguna tecnología puntual a priorizar?
Nosotros no les vamos a recomendar qué
usar específicamente. Nosotros le
estamos dando unos beneficios que ya
vieron aquí de participantes que dentro
de pocas horas ya le vamos a mandar cómo
redimir esos beneficios. Eh, pero no es
una recomendación. Ustedes pueden
utilizar lo que quieran. Obviamente
nosotros eh como Cor Subsidio es parte
de los clientes de GHC Pilot. También
vamos a tener una charla específica
sobre GIDHOC Pilot para que aprendan a
utilizarlo, pero no tienen una
recomendación específica de qué
tecnología utilizar. ¿Quiénes son los
mentores y es posible entrevistar a
personal de corsubsidio? Bueno,
justamente dentro de la el canal de
mentores vamos a tener espacio para que
los mentores van a unirse directamente
allí y ustedes van a poder hacerle las
preguntas directamente. Desde mañana va
a poder ver esos mentores directamente
en esa plataforma que les vamos a
brindar. Pero hoy eh les vamos a
comentar cuáles son algunos de los
mentores que están disponibles desde hoy
para hacerles preguntas, etcétera.
Ahora, eh es posible entrevistar al
personal de cosubsidio eh vamos a tener
a varios de estos a varios de los
mentores como parte del personalsidio, o
sea, o varios personas de corsubsidio
como parte de los mentores. Y ahí
validaré con Andrea a ver si podemos
tener algunos links eh para que a nivel
virtual ustedes puedan tener esos
espacios con ellos. De igual forma hoy
aprovechen que van a estar los líderes
justamente de cada uno de estos retos
para que ustedes les hagan preguntas
directamente, lo que ustedes quieran
preguntarle y lo que quede fuera de esos
espacios podemos hacerlo también en otro
momento. Van a pasar esto por escrito.
La eh toda la grabación va a quedar
disponible acá en YouTube. De igual
forma capaz podemos hacer como un
pequeño summarí de esto. Vamos a ver qué
tal. Pero todas estas reglas ya están
completamente disponibles para ver en
cualquier cualquiera de nuestras
plataformas. Igual el resto de cosas que
les acabo de decir que les voy a pasar,
el tema de los retos, de los recursos y
demás que van a estar disponibles a
partir de la próxima hora. Igual el tema
de los beneficios. ¿Hay algún problema
en incluir el en el proyecto componentes
de hardware si es posible? ¿Cómo se
evalúa de manera virtual?
Bueno, esa es una gran pregunta y de no
hay problema en que lo hagas, solamente
que pues va a ser complicado por
evaluarlo de manera virtual porque no
vamos a poder tocarlo, no vamos a poder
en este momento en el momento de hacer
el prefiltro y, incluso de que la el
jurado final lo vea, no vamos a poder
interactuar con él, pero si haces un
gran demo que nos demuestre que es
espectacular, tal vez sea la mejor
opción, no lo sé, Pero te lo dejo a tu
criterio porque, bueno, si no podemos
nosotros como jurados o el equipo de
jurados no puede interactuar con él
directamente, va a ser complicado que
que realmente podamos darle
sí la nota que se merece el proyecto,
incluso si es increíble, tal vez no va
no vamos a tener la capacidad de
evaluarlo de forma correcta.
¿A qué hora se puede inscribir inscribir
al grupo? Desde mañana van a tener la
disponibilidad. Vamos a intentar de que
sea lo más temprano posible. Igual le
vamos a mandar correo, le vamos a mandar
WhatsApp en el grupo de WhatsApp,
etcétera, para que tengan toda esa info.
Tiene que ser en equipo. Sí, los equipos
deben ser mínimo de tres personas,
máximo de cinco personas. Si ustedes
dicen que eh no, pero es que yo lo
quiero hacer solo, lamentablemente no lo
vamos a hacer de esa manera. ¿Por qué?
Porque este es un espacio donde queremos
que entre ustedes se integren, que entre
ustedes creen equipos que se puedan
convertir capaz luego en incluso
personas que le den tecnología
directamente a col subsidio, siendo eh
uno de los ganadores de los retos,
incluso pues ya tendrían ese esa
posibilidad de contrato muchísimo más
cerca. Eh, ¿qué pasa si de repente el
día de mañana el equipo que crean se
puede convertir en un startup? No lo
sabemos. Yo, por ejemplo, he tenido la
gran dicha de que en varios hackatons
termino conociendo y haciendo equipo con
justamente personas que después se
convierten en equipo de trabajo, que
después se convierten en cfounders,
etcétera, e incluso personas que hoy en
día conocí en algunos hacatons cuando
éramos solamente participantes y de
repente hoy en día ya algunos de ellos
son parte de los mentores que tenemos
acá. Así que dense la oportunidad de
conocer a otras personas, cómo lo pueden
hacer en el grupo de WhatsApp. eh
validan allí en el grupo que dice busco
equipo y tú puedes escribir, "Hola, mi
nombre es tal, me dedico a hacer X y Z.
Me interesa participar en el reto tal.
Hm, quisiera hacer equipo con con
alguien." ¿Listo? O incluso si ya tienes
una idea, puedes decir, "Hola, me
gustaría resolver el reto de seguros con
esta idea. Quienes quieran hacer equipo
conmigo, por favor escríbane. Estoy
buscando estos perfiles. Backen, Fronen,
eh alguien de marketing, no lo sé, lo
que a ti se te ocurra. Eso es bien
importante por allí. Los equipos se
conforman solo con personas registradas
en el evento. Sí, así es. Eh, solo con
las personas registradas, porque cuando
ustedes accedan a la plataforma mañana,
allí, por ejemplo, tienen que escribir
el el correo de la persona que solamente
va a existir
si esa persona se registró. Si no está
registrada, no está nuestra base de
datos, lamentablemente.
¿Cómo se maneja la tema de la propiedad
intelectual del código? Me encanta. Creo
que esta era una de las preguntas que
más esperaba que fuerasen a llegar. y
les voy a contar cómo se va a manejar. A
ver, si ustedes leen el términos y
condiciones, que muchos estoy segura que
no leyeron y por eso estaba preparada
para esta pregunta. Eh, dentro de los
términos y condiciones, les indicamos
que en la cláusula 6.3 los participantes
conservan la titularidad sobre los
desarrollos, propuestas, y estoy
leyéndolo para que sea bien exacto,
propuestas, prototipos y resultados
creados durante la hacat. también
conservan la propiedad intelectual
persistente. No hay sesión de derechos
por participar, pero hay una matiz
importante que es en la siguiente
cláusula. Al entregar el proyecto, el
equipo le otorga a col subsidio una
licencia limitada, no exclusiva y
gratuita por 12 meses, solo para
evaluación interna. Es decir, ustedes no
le están entregando con subsidio nada
por completo, solamente es para que
ellos puedan evaluar su proyecto para a
partir de allí eh analizar la
factibilidad y eventual estructuración
de una prueba de concepto. Esto quiere
decir que si ustedes resultan ganadores
en uno de los retos, van a pasar a este
a esta evaluación donde el equipo de
producto subsidio va a ver todo su
código, va a tener una reunión con
ustedes. Nosotros nos vamos a garantizar
de que vamos a garantizar que pase y a
partir de allí se puede estructurar una
prueba de concepto. Si todo queda
perfecto, ¿qué va a pasar? Se va a
avanzar con un piloto, una
implementación y eso puede ser piloto eh
como pr concepto, implementación,
codesarrollo, contratación o inversión.
Eso se va a negociar como parte de un
acuerdo independiente y por escrito
donde ustedes van a hablar directamente
con el equipo de cosupsidio, donde se va
a indicar las condiciones de la
propiedad intelectual en ese momento, la
remuneración definidas directamente en
esa negociación y esto es una
posibilidad, es decir, no es obligación
de col subsidio que todas estas eh todos
estos ganadores pasen a implementación,
pero obviamente la posibilidad es muy
alta, teniendo en cuenta que de 800
participantes justamente ustedes Si
quedan ganadores en un reto es muy alta
la posibilidad de que en efecto si pase
esta implementación. Así que espero que
eso los haya ayudado. De todas maneras
pueden buscar eh bueno, creo que ya no
están disponible porque cerramos la
inscripción, pero les vamos a mandar
como que los términos y condiciones para
que los lean allí. Eh, no sé si eso
quedó claro. Voy a revisar abajo. Me
parece superjo. Ay, me encanta esto. Me
encanta. Lo voy a poner acá. Me parece
super justo las condiciones de propiedad
intelectual. otros acat directamente te
la quitan. Excelente. Qué bueno que que
les guste estas condiciones. En efecto,
no queremos simplemente pum, te quito tu
tu solución y ya, sino realmente
queremos que esto sea un ganar ganar
para ambas partes. Pueden utilizar
varias, ¿sí? Todas las que quieran.
Quieren utilizar eh la que se llama X,
Yz, la que se llama P, no, la que
ustedes quieran. Todas pueden utilizar.
Pueden utilizar todas y cada una de las
herramientas que existan en el mundo.
Pueden utilizar lo que quieran, crear
las imágenes con la inteligencia
artificial que quiera, crear hasta el
pit con la inteligencia artificial que
quieran. Ustedes son libres. Este esaton
lo que vamos a evaluar es su es su eh
capacidad de crear con inteligencia
artificial sin importar qué herramienta
hayan usado. Incluso si ven en nuestras
charlas hay algunos de los mentores que
hablarán sobre alguna inteligencia
artificial y otro sobre otro modelo, así
que pueden utilizar todo lo que quieran.
Aquí son libres. Tendremos acceso a
alguien de operación de hotelería,
cocina de corsubsidio para entrevistar.
Hoy en la tarde vamos a tener a una
persona que ya es parte de este equipo
directamente para que pueda hacerle
todas las preguntas y si ustedes quieren
pedirle algo adicional pueden
preguntárselo. Pueden repetirnos cómo
conforman los equipos, sobre todo para
los que estamos solos aún. Okay. Sí, hay
dos maneras. Eh, van ahorita a las 11 y
por eso ya dentro de 10 minuticos voy a
cerrar porque uno me duele la garganta,
he hablado muchísimo y dos para no
aburrirlos tanto. Eh, ya a a las 11 de
la mañana, hora Colombia, es decir, en
media hora, van a tener la oportunidad
de entrar a un Zoom. Les vamos a mandar
el link de Zoom directamente por el
grupo de WhatsApp donde ustedes pueden
entrar y van a llegar allí. Hoy va a
estar Juliana que es parte del equipo
30X y los va a ayudar directamente a
conformar sus equipos. ¿Qué va a pasar
durante esa sesión? Juliana los va a
invitar a bien sea compartir. Hola, mi
nombre es tal y estoy buscando eh equipo
y hay otras personas que van a decir,
"Mfo, te te escribo." Listo. Y de una
vez ustedes van a poder quedar allí ya
eh conectados con las personas con las
que pueden hacer equipos. Esa es una
manera, pero si de repente a las 11 o
dentro de media hora estás ocupado por
alguna razón, puedes simplemente entrar.
En el WhatsApp hay un grupo que se llama
Busco equipo. En ese grupo puedes
agarrar y decir, "Hola, mi nombre es
tal. Estoy interesado en crear en crear
una solución para tal reto. Este es mi
perfil. ¿Quién a quién le gustaría hacer
equipo conmigo?" yas personas te van a
estar escribiendo. Ayer hubo demasiados
mensajes y sé porque muchos me han
comentado propiado después que gracias a
eso pudieron conseguir equipo
directamente.
Eh,
cada equipo solo puede hacer un reto o
se puede hacer más de uno? Es solo un
reto porque las los retos son bastante
diferentes entre sí. Entonces, solamente
un reto por proyecto y por equipo. En
este caso, para obtener créditos de
apoyo de Yemini, ¿cómo se hace? Vamos a
mandarles eh durante hoy, ¿sí? En las
próximas horas, le vamos a mandar
directamente cómo redimir todos los
créditos que que están disponibles.
Hola, Sandra. Hola, Jessie. A Jess la
conozco. Desde hoy podemos iniciar a a
desarrollar el proyecto. Sí, por
supuesto. Desde ya, desde las 9 de la
mañana ya podían hacerlo, así que
tranquilas. Incluso si lo hicieron desde
antes y como no habíamos dicho
exactamente a las 9 de la mañana,
digamos que hoy miércoles de temprano ya
podían hacerlo. ¿Qué lenguajes base de
datos y nubes y qué tipo de hardware usa
subsidio? Pregunto pensando desde ya en
la compatibilidad. Bueno, esto vamos a a
tratar de tener una sesión directamente
con el equipo de el equipo de tecnología
de colubsidio para que los ayude. Igual
de igual manera vamos a a buscar entrar
o sí que que tengamos un mentor
directamente de la parte técnica de
colubs que pueda apoyarlos allí. De
todas maneras, más que, o sea, no
queremos tampoco como ponerlos a ustedes
en una en un cuadrado, ¿no? Así que
ustedes pueden utilizar las herramientas
que ustedes deseen y pero siempre
pensando que capaz en el futuro vamos a
tener que cambiar un poco algunas bases
de datos, etcétera. Eh, lo importante es
que su eh su solución funcione para
resolver esos retos. De igual forma, eh,
José Gregorio, vamos a intentar
conseguirte a las personas de tecnología
directamente para que puedas hacerle la
pregunta. Allí los estaremos informando
por WhatsApp si logramos que entren y
ahí van a estar. Hola, ¿puedo trabajar
con mi equipo de mi empresa? Solo me
escribí yo. Ah, lamentablemente si tu el
resto del equipo de tu empresa no se ha
inscrito y no se inscribió, no podrías
trabajar con ellos. Si esa si esas
personas se inscribieron antes, podrías
trabajar con ellos. Entonces, eh si por
ahora eres la única de tu empresa que se
inscribió, pues tendrías que buscar otro
equipo. A ver, ¿qué más tenemos por acá?
preguntas sobre los retos en la
presentación. No sé si esto no esto no
lo entendí. Entonces
sigamos por acá.
Cor sucillo busca expandirse y tocar
nuevas poblaciones. Ah, bueno, ahí
Grego, si me puedes explicar la pregunta
en un mensajito, te ayudo, pero que no
sé, solamente hice preguntas sobre los
retos en la presentación y eso me
confunde. No sé a qué te refieres
exactamente.
Con subsidio busca expandirse y tocar
nuevas poblaciones donde no tiene acceso
actualmente. Esto se puede explotar en
la prueba o la mitad está enfocada en
los apartamentos donde ya tiene
cobertura. Hm. las los las soluciones
que ustedes deían proponer deberían
estar enfocadas en los retos. Los retos
están bastante claros allí. Sin embargo,
si tú quieres añadirle cómo expandirse,
adelante. Pues deberían buscar enfocarse
en resolver el problema, pero si de
repente resuelven el problema y pueden
resolver mucho más, son totalmente
libres de hacerlo. Tiene 5 días para
explorar su creatividad al máximo.
Eh,erá. para Ah, bueno, aquí esto es un
apoyo. Acá me pueden enviar el WhatsApp.
Vamos a Bueno, creo que yo lo puedo
compartir por acá. Voy a tratar de
enviárselos de una vez por este lado.
Eh, si entro, si no entro, alguna de las
charlas quedan grabadas. Sí, todas las
charlas van a quedar grabadas. Bueno, ya
te había comentado. Acá
se nos pierde un poco la información
valiosa en los chats de WhatsApp. ¿Hay
algún otro lado donde se pueda poner
como hilos? En este caso tiene el chat
de anuncios donde nadie más que nosotros
del equipo de 30x y por subsidio e si es
necesario vamos a mandarles información.
Así que la información importante va a
estar allí. El pit bien, el pich es el
mismo video del demo o son cosas
diferentes no. El pit es el mismo video
del demo. Ustedes tienen 2 minutos para
hacer su pit y su demo. Ahora, algo que
a mí me ha pasado en los otros acatos y
que les puedo recomendar que hagan es
que en vez de hacer un pit donde digan,
"Hola, mi nombre es tal y mi solución a
este problema es tal y aquí les muestro.
Este es el problema y esta es la
solución y ahora sí pasamos al demo."
No, traten de hacer su demo de una
explicando cómo lo que está mostrando
resuelve el problema. O sea, pueden
hacerlo de las dos maneras, pero a mí me
ha funcionado mejor en hacer el demo y
utilizarlo como pish de una vez.
Buen día. ¿Podemos empezar a construir
de inmediato? Gracias. Sí. A ver, ¿cuál
es? Ay, ¿cómo accedo al WhatsApp? Voy a
buscarles de una vez esto acá mientras
estamos hablando
para que de una ya tengan ese link.
Estoy en la comunidad, pero no me deja
agregar al WhatsApp. Eso no lo entiendo
exactamente porque sí debería dejarte
agregar. o dejarte ingresar a cualquiera
de los grupos. Dios mío, el WhatsApp
está explotado. Tengo miedo de cuando
termine esta presentación lo que voy a
encontrar allí. Voy a pasarles de una
vez el
enlace de invitación.
Aquí lo estoy dejando y ya lo van a
tener completamente disponible. Vamos a
tratar de acá lo estoy dejando y lo voy
a pinear acá. Entonces, aquí está la la.
A ver. Ay, no tenemos tantas preguntas
eh ahora. Perfecto.
Cada grupo eh puede elegir un solo reto.
Sí. Eh, la premiación por cada reto es
que cada
proyecto que sea primer lugar en cada
uno de los retos va a pasar a a
evaluación con implementación
directamente o a evaluación de
implementación directamente con col
subsidio y adicional van a obtener cupos
en programas 30x los ganadores por cada
reto. Y adicional a eso tenemos un eh
podio principal que son tres premios que
eso sí son generales.
Los créditos son por equipo,
participante, por participante.
Con subsidio puede modificar nuestro
código protectivo prototipo durante esos
12 meses y construir internamente una
solución derivada sin celebrar un
acuerdo adicional. Eh, no, eso va a ser
solamente en este caso para los que
hayan ganado, que van a entrar a esa
evaluación, pero con subsidio no tiene
derecho a hacer eso, solamente
solamente va a evaluarlo.
Y de hecho eh dentro de los términos y
condiciones tiene una cláusula que dice
que no puede comercializarlo, así que no
se preocupen, tienen que llegar a un
acuerdo con ustedes. Para el reto uno
dataset o tenemos que simular uno. El
reto uno creo que es el de crédito. Les
vamos a mandar por reto, vamos a
mandarles una carpetica que tiene por
dentro base de datos e información de
cómo utilizar esa base de datos. El reto
de crédito justamente no tiene dataset,
pero les vamos a mandar eh qué
información van a van a necesitar para
buscar solucionar eso. Ya, denme denme
un momento, ya se los voy a ayudar a
solucionar. Coruso maneja Microsoft en
su bañoría. Sí, eso es una respuesta
para José que preguntó antes. Juan
Manuel explicó que por temas
regulatorios si lo tiene cobertura. Ah,
bueno, esto debe ser otra cosa. Sería
bueno tener un grupo por cada reto. Muy
buena, muy buena idea, Misael. Vamos a
hacerlo.
A ver, ¿qué peso tiene la demo versus el
pit? Bueno, a ver, el demo y el pit son
casi que lo mismo porque son dos
minuticos donde tienes que hacer ambas
cosas. Eh, si te refieres al demo en
vivo o al link donde podemos utilizar tu
eh la plataforma, pues eso tiene un peso
importante porque la idea es que
imagínense lo siguiente, si ustedes le
van a decir a sus padres, mira, hice un
proyecto espectacular que te ayuda a, no
sé, transcribir todos tus mensajes de de
voz para que ya más nunca tengas que
escuchar una nota de voz. Si ustedes le
explican y le dicen lo maravilloso que
es, tu papá o mamá no te va a creer
tanto hasta que lo usen. Así que piensen
que nosotros vamos a ser igual hasta que
no lo usemos o que no podamos tener ese
link de ese MVP en vivo, es donde vamos
a a poder hacer jugar con esa con esa
solución y ver, ah, esto sí funciona
espectacular y eso es bien importante. Y
el pit que es parte del demo, en este
caso, es bien importante porque ten dos
minutos para para convencernos de que su
solución es la mejor.
Tengo una duda, somos tres equipos de
somos un equipo de tres personas, pero
solo me escribí yo porque pensé que era
suficiente. ¿Mis compañeros pueden
participar igual o cada integrante debe
registrarse? Cada integrante debió
registrarse, Lucas, eh podemos hm porque
ya se cerraron las inscripciones,
entonces lamentablemente eh te invitaría
a que busques a otros equipos
directamente en el equipo, en el chat de
busco equipo, porque la inscripción era
de forma personal, no de forma de
equipo.
A ver, no podía permitir a nuestros
equipos inscribirse media hora. Bueno,
vamos a pensarlo. Bueno, ya lo pensé. A
ver, hagamos algo. Les voy a dar hasta
las 11:30. Todavía no va a estar. Vamos
a tener desde las 10:50 hasta las 11:30
sus equipos de Lucas y de Mía Gestión
van a poder ingresar. Y si hay otras
personas que ya tienen esta que tienen
esta misma problemática, van a tener
hasta las 11:30. En este momento son las
10:40 de Colombia. Desde las 10:50 hasta
las 11:30 van a poder registrarse. Eso
lo vamos a hacer porque ya me lo están
preguntando mucho acá, entonces voy a
ser buena persona en este sentido.
¿En qué sitio podemos buscar equipo? En
el WhatsApp de en el en el grupo de
busco equipo. Listo. Creo que con esto
ya ahora sí tenemos todas las respuestas
dadas. Wow, no lo puedo creer, de
verdad. Pensé que que no se iba a acabar
nunca, pero me encanta. Muchas gracias
por hacer todas estas preguntas. Si eh
si tienen alguna otra, por favor déjenlo
en el WhatsApp y allí los vamos a
apoyar. Eh entiendo que hay algunas
cosas que nos faltan a nosotros
enviarles. El ejemplo los beneficios,
ejemplo, toda la información más
completa de los retos, pero lo vamos a
hacer durante el día, así que no se
preocupen. Cualquier otra duda que
tengan, por favor, déjenla. Cualquier
solicitud que tengan también déjenla por
allí. Estamos acá para apoyarles eh al
máximo. Eh somos más de 170 personas que
todavía seguimos en vivo, así que
genial, me encanta. Y bueno, Lucas y
Mía, ya saben, van a poder eh registrar
a sus equipos hasta las 11:30. Dentro de
10 minutos ya va a estar disponible y
también va a estar disponible lo que les
comentaba de los retos con los con los
recursos, etcétera. Así que bueno,
muchísimas gracias por haber venido. Me
encanta que hayan participado durante
estas casi 2 horas. Eh,
no se ve el número de de WhatsApp. No
puede ser, pero yo lo había puesto. Aquí
está. Déjame ver.
Eh, está más arriba, pero voy a
mandárselos nuevamente. Qué pena con
ustedes que no sé por qué no se fijó.
Oh, ah, aquí ya puedo fijarlo,
creo. Aquí está. Lo acabo de fijar
en YouTube. Porf revisen si está
funcionando.
Ahí está.
Ay, no les mandé lo que no era.
Ya les voy a mandar lo que es. Estamos
en vivo, amigos. Ahí les mandé la
presentación sin querer. A ver. Y bueno,
los siguientes pasos es elegir su reto,
formar su equipo y registrarlo en la
plataforma. Eso en la plataforma lo van
a poder hacer desde mañana. Ya les voy a
compartir el WhatsApp directamente
con ustedes que no lo había podido
hacer. Enlace de invitación a la
comunidad. Ya lo estoy copiando
y ya lo estoy pegando por acá y lo voy a
pinear.
Qué pena, amigos. Discúlpenme que les
mandé el enlace equivocado para que vean
que todo es en vivo y directo.
Replace fin message. Ahora sí, ahí lo
tienen
para que ingresen a la comunidad de
WhatsApp. Si estaban viendo esto y no se
han registrado y se va y se van a entrar
en el grupo de de WhatsApp, les cuento
que lamentablemente igual cuando entren
al a la plataforma y quieran subir su
proyecto o quieran entrar en alguno de
los equipos, no lo van a poder hacer
porque solamente van a hacerlo las
personas registradas. Así que es
importante tener ese en cuenta. Listo,
ya vamos a
ya vamos a continuar entonces a cerrar
esta esta pequeña ceremonia. Vamos a
mandarles toda la información durante el
día. A las 11 inicia en Zoom
directamente eh la formación de equipos
para aquellos que no tienen equipo
todavía y aquellos que no son como Mía y
eh y ¿cómo se llamaba la TIC Lucas? eh
que ya tenían equipo y de repente no se
habían podido incluir antes. Bueno,
todas esas personas que están buscando
equipo todavía pueden entrar a esa
sesión de Zoom. Juliana del equipo de
30X los va a ayudar directamente. Y
bueno, listo, allí vamos a a estar
apoyándoles en lo más posible para que
ustedes puedan conseguir su equipo. Hay
muchas personas buscando equipo, así que
no debería pasar que haya personas que
se queden solas. Así que adelante,
hablen mucho con las otras personas,
consigan eh los mejores personas para
compartir estos días y estoy muy muy
segura de que el domingo vamos a estar
muy felices con todo lo que vamos a
construir. Así que ya con eso
finalizado, les doy mucho muchas gracias
por por venir a esta sesión y cualquier
pregunta porfa, la hacen directamente en
el WhatsApp. Hasta luego.